Oh,
like an hour extra and get culinary.
Talking about stuff.
One zero.
The stars have aligned.
The prophecy has come true.
Alex Jones and Eddie Bravo together on
episode nine.
One one.
This is episode nine slash 11 in the
podcast.
No,
I'm not.
I had a fucking work hard all week to
grind out podcast to make sure that I
hit episode nine slash 11 when we booked
it.
I knew how I go.
Okay.
There's a certain number of podcast I
have to do to get this to nine slash 11.
So Jane and I worked it out and we did
it.
Let me just say I'm very envious because
I'm in my studio under bright lights and
I've talked about going back to when I
was just on radio that darkness,
we can really think this is a wonderful
studio.
I'm going to do a studio.
My next one with a fire pit.
I'm going to have conversations outside.
I've talked to about that because it's
like primitive.
It triggers now and that it's
comforting.
It feels good and it's kind of cool
lighting.
So that's the next studio we build.
I'm going to build a fire pit,
going to get some log,
some actual real fire.
You can only do that like certain times
of the year in la though.
Like when they,
when they have fire season,
they wouldn't let you do that shit.
We will usually have like a little
balcony or like a little outside
courtyard with your fire pit and you
Kinda,
you have.
I don't want a real fire pit,
you know,
like I feel like if you're going to have
a fire pit with sharing bonfire,
you should have an actual law.
You should move to Hawaii part of the
year and I will too.
And then we'll just have a big fire in
the jungle and create a whole
renaissance.
Just what we're talking Donald Trump.
Helicopter secretly.
Secretly he thinks that that could fix a
lot.
We could fix a lot with that.
I was showing you.
You like a decorated a correspondent for
the news.
Now what the fuck's going on?
What do you mean?
I mean,
you're a euro,
euro official White House Guy now,
right?
Like you're actually like a news guy,
like a 100 percent legit.
We'll verify the bureau and stuff,
but that's just part of it,
but like you're,
you're in deep with the trump
administration.
Well,
I've had trump on and I talked to him
so.
But I mean really.
He's your buddy.
Really,
really.
It's just that we're covering the
resurgence of America.
What made the country great lower taxes,
empowering the people,
bringing people together.
The opposite of what MSM said.
What's happening is mainstream media is
literally almost dead.
It's collapsing.
I mean,
look at you.
I remember having dinner with you like
six,
seven years ago and you're like,
yeah,
we got a million downloads a week.
Now it's $90 million or whatever it is,
a month and 20 million on Youtube.
And for Info wars it's similar numbers.
It's a good week.
Forty dollars million.
We've had as many as 85 million people
listen on radio and tune into videos in
one week.
That was election week,
but our normal 40 something million.
It's just crazy.
How can they compete with that?
They're still delusional.
They advert CNN show is like a million
viewers.
Fox things.
It's the big swinging deck.
It's got $3 million.
It's all,
I'm sorry,
people transmitting and broadcasting to
geriatric homes,
you know,
where you see Fox News and CNN and
nursing homes,
you know,
what you see with kids 10 years old,
10 years old at the college and beyond
the Rogan experience
and it's infowars and it's always other
folks.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's a weird time as an NBA teams like
those shows where you have to tune in
from eight to nine and you have to sit
through the commercials.
That's kind of all gone away because of
dvrs because now people will just have
to wait a few minutes.
He could dvr through all the commercials
or you record things after the fact.
I have ever.
You'd like 15 years ago saying the
internet killed television.
They haven't announced that yet.
You Watch it's going to kill it because
how can they compete with what you can
do on the Internet?
You know,
a guy getting screwed by a horse or
whatever it is.
How the hell can you compete with all
this craziness?
Did you see the guy in China?
They got jacked by the tiger today?
Oh,
I did see that yesterday,
actually it was yesterday.
Let me look,
let me not pick it mission and just go
through here.
Well,
they even shot at the tiger.
So the scattered the Tigers,
they shot at the Tigers to get them off
this dude.
And then even after the bullets were
shot off,
this tiger was like,
no,
fuck that.
I'm going back in.
And he ran in after they shot at him and
finally killed a dude and it was all.
Everybody's got their phone up and
they're all filming it fell in or jumped
in.
He jumped and he wanted to get killed.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He would know this.
That was another guy who went in with a
line and try to convert them to
Christianity touristy there.
That guy.
It's crazy.
Whenever the Bible and he's trying to
convert the lines line just fucked him
up.
I'll tell you what's crazy about that
though is imagine trying to convert him.
Maybe he was just like praying that the
motherfucking line when he know he went
in on his own,
he was talking to them in the name of
Jesus and he was like talking to.
You never seen it.
Jamie.
Pull it up.
Definitely.
Probably Schizophrenia.
See,
here he is.
He gets in there and he's.
He's talking to the lines.
This motherfucker just jumped the fence
and decided he was going to convert the
lines of Christianity and lions are
apparently like way cooler than tiger.
What is going on here?
Tigers see people and they just fucked
him up immediately.
The line like barely fuck that guy up.
He just kind of slips because they're,
they're more tribal or more like dogs
pack animal there.
The only cat that a pack or a group.
So they're not,
you know as agro.
Exactly.
When a tiger sees you,
you're in my territory,
I'm going to kill you.
Yeah.
Tiger is a totally different beast.
Like tiger.
Sometimes they'll like adopt another
little animal,
like a wild dog or something like would
be licking on it.
Big Knife to it and tell them what to
say it.
Yeah.
The d word stuff,
remember the only way you could see this
before is with those animal attack
videos.
Remember those animals know we started
the same way.
They always start off with a dog attack,
a dog attacking a mailman and Iguanas
out attacked your leg,
and then it slowly ends up with drunk
Mexicans at a Rodeo on a wild bull with
a rope and those bulls are smart as hell
and they drag them these drunk Mexicans
and they dragged their heads along the
rails and just crushed these dudes in
between the railing.
Like some serious brain trauma.
Yeah,
vicious brain trauma.
They need one
word it with just 100 percent of that
because that was the most exciting shit.
Alex Jones.
How the fuck is TV getting compete with
that?
So that's what we're saying.
Yeah.
They can't compete.
So that was kind of wrong though because
Netflix is tv and it's also the
Internet.
It's like both things.
Sure.
It's forcing the power of Hollywood
basically dispersed though.
Yeah.
Well they.
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's better if it gets.
If,
if the ability to get your workout gets
to more people.
It's better,
it's better if anybody can do like the
new competition in these new youtube
stars,
like all they have to do is stand in
front of a camera and this zero
production value,
they don't have.
I mean,
if you've got a camera,
you've got an Internet connection,
you can have a youtube show.
People find you interesting.
All of a sudden you've got millions and
millions of subscribers.
I mean,
Eddie was bringing up this fact for your
audience up front.
A lot of MSM lies and says,
I'm this big right wing guy,
but you guys know that I was really
against George w Bush all you where you
were arrested early on in the Bush
administration.
I remember when,
when we first became friends in 1999,
we were running around the White House
are the,
uh,
the state capital lawn with,
with,
with George Bush junior and senior masks
on.
And you were always again,
sure the bush supported trump is the
entire power structure of the media.
I mean the Vatican,
the communist Chinese or Saudi Arabians
all put money in and said,
stop him,
stop him.
And then lives that.
The Russians were giving him money with
no proof and so the issue is he's simply
trying to actually be president and not
have special interest in their running
him and that's why the whole power
structure is against trump.
So Andy was asking before we went live,
well,
how is it you're this outside guy
against the establishment,
but now you're for it.
No,
trump's trying to create a beachhead.
You just to explain it,
to try to take the country back and
actually devolve power back to the
states and back to the people doesn't
mean he's perfect,
but notice the stock market went up a
trillion,
$200,000,000,000
a year,
just the last month or so because a lot
of institutional investors and others
understand what trump is trying to
create real prosperity,
not a bunch of social engineering and
I'm not here to pitch trump to people.
The issue is is that there were major
intelligence agencies and and patriots
and the government who were sick of what
was happening and we're sick of,
of of Hillary and Obama backing jihadist
groups,
other things,
and so they're rolling those groups up
right now.
They really are standing up against them
and this is a historic moment and and so
there's been a counter-coup through the
electoral process in our country and
that's what wikileaks was.
That wasn't the Russians.
That was US intelligence agencies.
I said two months ago that Anthony
Winter in New York,
you know,
who might have a dean's husband,
the former congressman,
a that was working for Hillary.
I said that he's under investigation for
child porn.
Okay.
And then now it came out yesterday that
they're looking at indicting him for
child porn.
While I had that from the NYP that came
out yesterday.
Wow.
Why would,
what did he do?
He had something on his computer.
Well now that they won't tell us,
but I was told that tied into that whole
pizzagate thing,
which again,
the media misrepresented what we said
and did.
It came out and all those wiki leaks,
all these weird coats.
Okay.
Like there was a bunch of weird codes
about pizza and about a piece of pizza
and Obama wants $65,000
in hot dogs delivered and they're like,
are these really good hot dogs?
Hot dogs weren't as good last time.
Well,
these are succulent on dogs.
That's not about kids.
Do you have to be?
Well,
what is that about?
It's male prostitutes.
I mean,
that's what the code means really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
How do they get male prostitutes to see
keep your fucking mouth shut?
Well,
cause you know,
bad things happen if you don't.
Federal Child Porn charges possible for
Anthony Wiener.
But,
but I'm on record months ago.
I'm on record months ago saying that
that's the case because I had those
sources and show the government good
elements of the government know what's
really going on.
So the media that Mesh misrepresented
and said,
oh look at four Chan,
they're talking about a thing called
pizzagate and some pizza place in DC and
the media looks at it and says,
Oh,
Alex Jones is claiming all this bad
stuff's happening at this pizza place.
I'm like,
what is this?
So they divert some probably innocent
pizza place to distract off of all the
emails that the New York police have and
the FBI have.
That's just this monstrous reported
pedophile network.
So to just credit that they could create
a fake story hoping we jump on it to
then divert over to that story and then
once we're on that,
it diverts everybody off from Anthony
Wiener,
what hats,
which reportedly,
which leads reportedly to a larger
network.
So they're playing that far ahead so
they're,
they're literally attacking a pizza
place with fake stories just so that
people can focus on that and take
attention off.
Anthony Wiener.
Yes,
because I was connected to that story.
It was connected to Podesta stuff in
deceased or in New York and all this
other crazy stuff.
So I love saying because we're making a
lot of like long sentences here and a
lot of long statements,
but let's,
let's fear a lot of people that are
going.
What the fuck is pizza gate?
There was this Ben Swan guy who did this
recent piece about it and a lot of
people got very angry.
Did you see the piece?
See the piece that he did?
It seemed to me to be pretty measured
and he was making some connections too,
between that little symbol for child
pedophilia.
Yes.
And uh,
we're just pedophilia era,
right?
And the logo,
the logo for the pizza place,
he also made,
did he make the hastert connection with
Podesta,
pastored a confirmed child molester and
best buddies would pedesta and former
speaker of the house.
And then you expand on that.
But let's,
let's just do it step at a time because
this is really kind of important stuff.
So that's all 100 percent true.
Right?
So it's true that hastert it's in jail.
It's true that hastert is a known
pedophile that a judge called a serial
pedophile,
right?
Yeah,
that's true.
Is One hundred percent.
It's true.
The Podesta was friends with hastert.
That's 100 percent,
right?
Yes.
And then all this other stuff now
becomes odd,
doesn't it become odd?
And,
but if you say it's odd,
if you look at it,
this bents one guy with this,
what I thought was he was just kind of
expressing what is weird about this
case.
And when he did it,
he got so much shit over it.
I was kind of shocked.
I was kinda shocked people were calling
him a moron and the same thing.
But,
but that's what I'm saying,
they build a straw man.
So imagine thousands of emails come out
with them talking about we'll have the
kids ready.
Six,
seven and eight in the hot tub at this
time.
And there didn't see anything like that.
Oh,
it gets.
It gets really weird.
Where did it say that it was in the
emails?
There's thousands of them,
but it said we'll get the kids in the
hot tub.
Yes.
I never saw that.
Can you?
Can you see if you could find that to
me?
That seems like just the whole thing is
so bizarre.
It's like we're going to have the kids
delivered for entertainment.
There'll be in the hot tub now.
These are great kids,
but kids can be kids.
We know what's fucked up about it is how
few people really mentioned that
connection to hastert.
I always thought that would be a huge,
huge,
constant Jonah love the fact that there
are very astute.
I just bring up this whole big topic of
how they twist things.
You go right to the key points that,
okay,
Barney frank,
who got caught running a underage male
prostitute ring in the nineties out of
his three story townhouse,
you.
I thought it was just a male prostitute
thing.
I didn't know somewhere and then,
but listen,
I was with them all the way up to age 19
plus or whatever,
but then what happened is he goes on
Cspan on the house floor and says,
if you continue to investigate this,
I'm going to expose the half of you that
are involved in this,
in this room,
and the investigation got shut down.
So the reason this is important,
as for shadow government,
you need something so bad that everybody
who's involved in it ever,
ever comes out will be destroyed.
So that binds them all to the secrecy.
So that's where child pornography comes
in and that's where pedophilia comes in
and that's where you get so many of the
elite being into it,
but just as you shed,
you have the Republican establishment
trying to get mastered out of nowhere as
a wrestling coach to run for office.
Then reportedly,
he's the pure career.
Just like Penn state and just like they
had something Dusky Dusky and the under
age kids,
they were quote mentoring,
getting farmed out to supposedly big
donors.
What's this is who we're talking about.
Two very specific cases where two very
different cases,
but what's crazy is they're both real.
It's both real 100 percent send Dusky
who is a very respected man.
The community did a lot of charity work
with a young disenfranchised children
and was molesting them at the same time
and was super respected in the community
and he was the right hand man to Joe
Paterno.
So that whole thing just fell apart in
the headquarters from our research with
the pedophilia is like Pennsylvania.
Okay.
That's the Franklin cover and that's,
that's,
that's the.
That's up in public.
What does this see?
Jamie says we plan to heat the pool,
so a possibly Bonnie will be uber
service to transport Ruby Emerson and
Mave Lozado,
11,
nine and almost seven.
So you'll have some further
entertainment and they will be in that
pool for sure.
What in the fuck?
That's the only one of them.
That's a real confirmed emails.
Yes,
Jesus Christ.
Listen,
here's the problem.
So I have in ypd telling me before the
election,
like a month,
yes,
we're investigating wayner child porn
photos.
Go back to that please.
I want to not just have kids out on the
Internet but,
but kids he's communicating with and
their parents are basically letting them
communicate with him.
If I'm told this by didn't,
why PD detectives,
I mean the secret service gave me
information about how hillary was
collapsing all the time.
Remember we reported that and then it
got caught on tape.
So,
so show.
All this stuff goes on and on and on.
And so I'm not saying half the people or
or,
or 90 percent of them are,
are,
are guilty or innocent mall.
This all I know is we start covering it,
start asking questions.
They then divert off into somebody on a
fortune for forum pointing out.
There was some email about a meeting at
some pizza place in DC.
We're top Democrats.
Cow.
They then turned the whole thing into
I'm blaming some pizza place.
I'm sending shooters into shoot people
at a pizza place,
makeup all this crazy ass crap when I
never even said any of that,
and then you go back to me two months
ago,
three months ago,
I said,
the police have told me they're
investigating wiener for pedophilia and
child porn when it was not in the news
now known as it's in the news.
What I'm saying?
Okay,
Elise,
slow down.
Before we get away from this,
because I got to go back to that.
There was a quote up there that are that
Jamie pull up that I wanted to read the
one on the lower bottom about this.
Now this,
these are the emails that you were
talking about and these are 100 percent
confirmed emails.
Go back to that one.
That was on the bottom.
Scroll down to the.
And I'm not saying any of these people
are guilty.
Yeah.
What is that?
Hold on a second here.
So six grownups with two toddlers and
two infants spread throughout the house
and sure enough one of the toddlers was
rubbing my nose at 5:45.
What the fuck does that mean?
The FBI as a whole got back to retrieve
the children they threw in the towel and
what?
I don't know,
man.
This is like,
I don't know what the fuck those emails
mean,
but look,
let's just now everybody wants
immediately shoe this away as disgusting
when possible.
We're talking about two very specific
proven cases,
right?
Hastert,
proven Sandusky,
proven real huge elite,
powerful people that were also active
pedophiles,
right?
Yes.
So that's a fact.
Who Know each other in our bodies and
then you've got Podesta's brother who's
big in Washington in an article in 2007
in the Washington Post.
I'm going to give you the exact
headline,
which was something like a radical art
or something and it's like naked photos
of the neighborhood.
Kids in their house and then they're
showing it,
throwing it in your face.
It's,
it's,
it's just crazy.
But that's not even stuff I get into but
there.
But there is something to that because
some of his artwork was super disturbing
that he had in his house like this pink
buckets.
There were there were in their underwear
and it looked like they had been paddled
and they were all standing there with
their butts facing very.
It was more about this than others.
See,
and that's all I do is cover these real
tanks.
Don't give you the new nurse,
but that is real.
The government pissed off about this.
The pedophile rings.
We've gotten so big that the
intelligence agencies began to leak all
this info and I knew Hillary was
planning to steal the election.
She did steal five states according to
the experts.
And briefly how did she do that?
I wouldn't mean trying to break into six
days.
It's not go on these long rants where
there's a bunch of different statements
that need to be addressed.
So let's just from right there,
you got to get to that.
Like how did she steal five states can
kind of gloss over that.
Okay.
No,
she tried to.
How did she tried to steal six days?
She did steal five states.
Well,
Bev Harris was a big liberal Democrat at
the Hbo Documentary,
Hacking Democracy.
She's the leading expert.
She was actually a month before the
election through whistleblowers got the
actual code that had been loaded on
machines all across the country should
ever in studio to steal the election.
I saw hacking democracy and I saw that
they did engineer those voting machines
that you could have a third party input
and change it and that it on live on the
show.
And that was a decade ago with Bush.
This is new.
Okay.
Just wanted.
She's the top election fraud expert.
So she comes on my show,
uh,
the stories on infowars.com.
And she says,
uh,
we've got evidence.
And then I had the hacking experts on
and I had the industry whistle blowers
on and I had the county officials on at
every level we have the fraud proven
that Democrat connected grips.
We're already loading code on a machines
all over the country,
but it's different complex.
But about thing was 18 percent of the
machines in the country to be able to
remotely break in and,
and flip votes show because they were
aware of that.
A bunch of states were waiting and
watching and homeland security broken
live into six dates and kept trying to
flip the results,
and they even have screenshots and
videos of them in the computers in there
clicking and doing it all.
There's major investigations going on.
You heard the news,
trump's crazy.
He claims illegals voted to make it
about illegals.
That was one statement and a larger
election fraud deal of actual computers
show.
So trump knows about all this,
so she comes on and says they're
planning this fraud.
Then she comes on after the election and
she says,
yes,
it's clear.
Here's where precincts close.
Here's where all this happened,
where 100 percent went for Hillary or
right after it closed,
all the votes then came in.
We're 100 percent for Hillary.
They didn't even care,
but the landslide was so big for trump.
They couldn't steal it.
She successfully stole five states.
She tried to break into six others or
her controllers did and got blocked.
The tsunami for trump was so huge with
the real politic.
We can break down later that they still
weren't able to steal it,
and now patriots inside US intelligence
agencies are preparing to roll up the
pedophile networks nationwide.
So you've seen arrest in Pennsylvania,
arrested in La.
I haven't seen these arrests.
Who's getting there?
It's just now breaking and it.
It's.
It's big institutionalized.
One hundred 74 arrests,
28 sexually exploited children rescued
during statewide human traffic
operation.
They're getting mentally,
she has a takeover,
right?
Holy Shit.
But look at the numbers.
They're 474 people arrested,
but there are only rolling up the rin
fields that get the people for the
psychic vampires know insane.
Is it that this is still happening?
Right?
So all the people that thought that,
this idea that,
you know what
I mean,
whether they tried to make it ridiculous
by calling a pizza gate are connected
into a pizza place.
Everybody that thought that was
ridiculous.
It is ridiculous that there could
potentially be some sort of a pedophile
ring and see how they tricked Turkish.
They go pick some pizza place.
Probably have their people go on,
make comments on some message board.
CNN,
New York Times,
Washington Post the same day,
come out and say all the emails are
discredited from New York and California
and Hawaii because there's this innocent
pizza place over here that some of the
Democrats go to and they're all saying
that's where the pedophiles are at.
Okay,
so then the Internet all goes in,
looks at that and starts trying to prove
to disprove msm that,
oh,
there must be something going on there.
So then that turns that all into the big
quagmire as a smokescreen from all the
admitted stuff that's happening because
I was told by my Nyp d high level
sources that they've got all this stuff
on wieners computer that just got
scooped up during the whole hacking
story and the whole story about Hillary
and the unsecured servers and that that
was being blocked by Obama and that as
soon as trump got in,
they would go back after winter.
Then I was told about former section
chief from the CIA that indeed this was
an operation that we're running against
him to start leaking all this.
And so what you're beginning to see is
the beginning of all the pedophilia
coming out as they roll up the procurers
that grabbed your kids out of backyards
or that go out as social workers and get
the kids or whatever.
They're rolling all those up right now
to get the renfield.
Renfield brings the people to Dracula
because that's the allegory.
I'm not saying it right,
but I know what you're saying.
So they're gonna now.
Roll it up into the higher level groups
right now.
Here's what's going on with a lot of
this stuff.
You have to be real careful in how you
describe these things and how you talk
about these things because people are
looking for any little tiny thing to
discredit it and one of the reasons why
they're looking at it,
they're doing it for personal reasons
because it seems you no one wants to be
ridiculous.
No one wants to be a fool and no one
wants to be someone who's talking about
conspiracies that aren't real.
So people are very hesitant to talk
about something that's unproven but
horrific.
Just like 15 years ago,
it was a conspiracy theory that the
Catholic Church had any pedophelic.
Now we know 30,
30 percent we're doing it.
We now know the old pope had to step
down,
was blackmailed within fall about other
high level preached by the new guy that
came in.
Uh,
I mean this is heavy.
It's the,
the,
the Catholic church stuff is absolutely
horrible and proven over and over again.
And again,
when I was a kid,
it was rumor,
it was just things that were whispered.
You would hear about it.
And now it's.
I always wondered how they're getting
away with it.
It's so out in the open.
How come there isn't more of a psychic
vampire stealing the energy from the
kids?
Well,
what the most common thing they do find
very often in jail,
the most common thing they do is they
find very troubled kids that don't talk
about it.
People with foster care,
kids with no parents.
Kids who come from really troubled
backgrounds who were abused like
Sandusky,
ran a abused children's shelter and
Grove
and then would take the kids out
sometimes overnight.
It rich people's houses to make them
feel better.
Yeah.
It's.
And then no one wants to believe that
the is that the assistant coach and that
all these powerful people.
But when he finally got caught,
he was raping eight year olds in the
showers at noon on a Saturday at the
field house.
Yeah.
And someone who worked there,
found it,
watched it happen,
walked in on them literally.
And that's what it all fell apart.
And that's what always happens.
Those guys get more and more arrogant.
And so all I'm telling you is I'm not
saying anybody's guilty and these
thousands of emails,
you go read them and it's like the last
walnut sauce you brought wasn't very
good.
Oh,
well these are good walnuts.
You're going to.
Oh,
I love walnuts.
And then you go read in the FBI
breakdown what?
That's code for.
What's called for Walnut means people
with Brown skin.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Well,
Gunderson was talking about this for
years.
FBI chief formula.
He discovered a bunch of it,
uh,
in Los Angeles.
He was,
he was the head of the La Sector.
So people are gonna hear this.
And they go,
oh,
they're a bunch of pizza gate troopers.
These guys are a bunch of pizza.
Great Truth.
There's,
there's,
there's an inclination to automatically
dismiss things.
Let me be clear,
let me be clear.
I am on the covering 50 topics a day.
These emails are coming out.
I get contact with one of my sources by
people in the NYP ed.
I get sent documents,
photos of their licensed law
enforcement.
I talked to these people.
Then they say,
yeah,
no,
it's horrible.
It's a bunch of pedophilia.
Um,
you know,
it,
it's a bunch of child porn.
It's all gonna come out.
It's tied to all these different groups.
And I'm just like,
okay.
So I go on air and I say,
listen,
I got this from real NYP and at other
sources.
And then Erik Prince of Blackwater still
rests with the biggest groups in the
world.
Does he run some sort of military
operation?
And I'm like Bahrain,
our Saudi Arabia.
Absolutely.
The point is,
is that he comes back says,
is that the UAE can ask you about it.
He knows all about it.
But the point is,
is that all this happens and he comes
out in the news.
Okay,
through the lighthouse,
Oregon,
breitbart basically from trump's mouth
and says,
yes,
we've confirmed high level pedophilia
rings in the Clinton operation.
We're going to bring them down.
And so that's what all this is.
Why did Breitbart tweet about that in
2011?
Do you remember that tweet,
right?
Barton knew about it.
Came out right?
Bart said,
I'm going to bring out the biggest thing
that's going to bring down the
Democrats.
And they poisoned him right here in
California.
Initially poisoned,
you know?
Absolutely.
They killed him.
Where did what happened?
I didn't even know how he died.
He,
I thought he died of a heart attack.
Is that what?
Are you laughing?
Fake laughing and pull up the.
I'm laughing.
Just.
No,
I know you're in the media.
I'm a pull up bar out Joe.
I won't buddy.
You know.
I love you.
Anyway,
pull up the breitbart email or the
Breitbart tweet because it's a crazy.
Joe knows all about this.
Well,
the tweet is pretty insane.
When you read it,
you're like,
wait,
what the fuck is going on?
Like every.
There's an instantaneous reaction that
people have their intelligence,
right?
You're right.
You're already telling me people are
doing this to kids.
You don't get the fuck out
of here.
That's nonsense,
but when you tell people about the stuff
that's been proven,
the ones that have their own account,
they don't call.
They don't attach those.
I was on Air Shang.
I'm told this by NYP ed in like three
different shows and that there's going
to come out that leaner sending child
porn and it's in the news today what
they're saying,
what they're accusing Wiener of
apparently sending sexually explicit
text to an underage girl.
That's what's against the law.
So the calling the child porn,
but it's essentially he was sending
pornographic text to a 15 year old.
Yeah,
well I was told it's a lot more than
that.
What they're doing is minimizing it
because the higher ups are being told
you don't let this out.
Let me tell you.
Wiener supposedly had tens of thousands
of emails.
Wiener should be a fucking comedian for
sure.
He's a freak.
He's got real problems.
He's a good communicator.
A Betty's hilarious.
Come on,
don't you think?
All I know is I'm not saying even
wieners a pedophile.
All I know is all I know is.
Listen,
we all know about Jerry Epstein.
Okay.
And that don't know about Jerry the
Lolita Express.
Just Google that.
And what does that.
Bill Clinton was on 20 flights first it
was.
Oh,
that's right.
Okay.
Has a temple in it.
And then he was also flying to this
Middle Eastern country with this chic
that's admitted pedophile with
multimillion dollar checks at Bill
Clinton on the plane.
And Bill Clinton's a known sexual
predator.
Okay.
So all this stuff's going on.
And shall they start bringing up
lawsuits against Donald Trump with Jane
Doe's claiming he'd been with Epstein
even though there's no proof and the law
because they make you log in on private
jets.
None of it was ever true.
He'd been at here is how Prague,
Prague Progressive Guru John Podesta is
in household name is worldclass under
age,
sex,
slave up cover up or defending.
Unspeakable dregs escapes me early on.
Did John Podesta.
Imagine his baby m,
m,
F A.
I don't know what that is.
Would be covering up for underage sex
ops in H ow.
Hate crimes against blacks.
Don't know what that means.
Um,
what does m,
m,
f a young Jamie media matters.
Huh?
Isn't that still rose?
Yeah,
that's us.
But also guess who owns the pizza place?
Who were all this one on its,
it's media matters.
Head guy.
David Brock's boyfriend and that is
where they have major democratic party
fundraisers.
And then they had,
they had rock bands there that,
that gave live spoken word dissertations
of the love of children.
What I'm talking about guys liking golf?
Drag con about how much they love
children.
Have you seen this?
Yeah.
I don't even really want to repeat what
they really pull it up.
One is a video of them saying that it
was the comments,
which is a comet ping pong.
So do you know what?
Why is really.
It's a very,
very bizarre subject.
But why is this like.
So what is this right here?
You bring it up,
Jamie.
Okay.
Give me some volume.
Great thing.
Can you are below a sandwich?
Sharp shooter read is
two.
Came down here.
He likes the world sounds.
We listening to his manager.
That's super weird.
That first of all,
does Comet Ping Pong?
Anybody listening?
Let's describe what that person looked
like.
They were wearing a wig,
a blonde wig,
and it was a guy transvestite or a woman
who's just smoked every cigarette.
It's one of the two.
But uh,
this is the fact that that was going on
at that place.
Seems really odd.
But that sounds like someone ad libbing,
you know,
we all have preferences.
I was trying to be funny,
like it's almost like in the,
in the,
in the little boy.
Oh yeah.
A lot of creepy artwork and I'll talk to
that guy.
Lot of creepy artwork.
I mean,
that's a fact.
There's a lot of facts.
So it's one of those things are not
saying that I'm not either.
That's what's really important.
I never even really covered this stuff.
And then they had me on the news and
also swan going,
they said these people were killing kids
in a basement.
They say,
okay,
I'm Megan Kelly went on and took a clip
where I was talking about Hillary show
funding jihadis and and Obama back in
the Arab spring that killed tens of
thousands of people,
hundreds of thousands of people,
thousands of children now.
Al Qaeda was putting kids,
which is Isis,
into sex slavery.
They edited that out and then cut it
together on Fox News with me.
Shane and Hillary Clinton ranks and
kills children in a basement at ping
pong pizza.
They literally now edit audio,
but I was able to get changed your
audio.
I was able to go find the day with video
with what I really said and throw it
back in their face.
Wow.
That's really blatant.
That's what.
Where's this?
Can we watch this?
Where?
Where is this that they did that?
You guys have to come the comparison of
the two up?
Yeah.
It's something like Megan Kelly caught
at giant lie against Alex show.
I'm trying to find that we should.
We should play that fast.
First of all,
Megan Kelly,
so pretty.
She could say whatever the fuck she
wants.
I think she looks like an old training.
I love her.
Do things loosely.
An old training.
You're hilarious.
No,
I don't like old trainings,
but I think she's hot.
You know,
like you don't think Meghan Kelly's.
Now I just want to insult this globalist
global.
Obviously she's pretty.
Do you know Joe?
She's real ugly.
She.
Do you think that she was.
She's moved over to NBC.
Do you think she's going to change your
tune now and go for the little niece?
She wants to be the quote New Fox News
show.
They'll be the near kind of Glenn Beck.
I'm a conservative,
but I hate conservatives and
Libertarians and I speak for everyone
and I can decode it all so she shouldn't
go over there and be the conservative
light and try to get them some ratings.
So it seems
like NBC realized is that's where the
money.
Is that what you're saying?
Want to see how fake news is made from
Meghan Kelly on Fox News?
Did you find it Jeremy?
Okay,
let's play it here.
Here we go.
Give us some volume.
This whole thing.
Got Pizza Gate conspiracy gun man.
Many controversies.
Do these days,
it began with a tweet on October 30th
days after the FBI announced they'd be
reopening and investigation into Hillary
Clinton's emails.
Someone on twitter who's name remains
unverified but has several thousand
followers,
posted that new emails found on Anthony
Wiener's.
Computer confirmed that Hillary Clinton
was involved in a pedophilia ring.
The twitter post included information
from a facebook user who stated,
quote,
my Nyp dea source said it's much more
viable and serious.
Then classified material on wieners
device.
We're talking in international child
enslavement and sex room.
The next day.
Places shouldn't be,
but backing up to the second now,
this is probably trying to debunk us.
What they do is they misrepresent what
we're saying,
so again,
whoever these rogue people were or or I
don't know who they are saying,
oh,
look in ypd says it's wiener and all
this.
She highly,
we're saying,
none of that's happening now.
It's actually starting to come out.
I don't know how far,
how deep it goes,
but this is when Kelly,
let's let it play out and respond to it
afterwards.
Otherwise,
we're gonna.
Go ahead.
This is the right one book user who
stated,
quote,
my Nyp dea source said it's much more
viable and serious then classified
material on wieners device.
We're talking in international child
enslavement and sex ring the next day.
The bogus claim was picked up by a
website called your newswire.com
message boards like four Chan and reddit
right wing blogs and several pro trump
websites.
Info wars,
Alex Jones,
Afar right web host posted a youtube
video seen almost 500,000
times
personally.
I have zero fear Kenny up against you.
The rumor spread,
inspiring some new found Internet
sleuths to start digging around in John
Podesta's hacked emails,
searching for proof and location of the
so called sex ring.
What they found were numerous references
to pizza.
Now,
here's what our Jones
set resistance to tyrants is obedience
message to Hillary.
What I think about children,
Hillary Clinton has personally murdered
the chopped up,
right to have zero fear of standing up
against know you heard me right it.
Hillary Clinton has personally murdered
children.
Go tell that loan liar.
Can't hold back anymore until the
rivalry.
Clinton is one of the most vicious
serial killers
the planet's ever seen.
There's a twist to that,
talking about the devil worship story
with her chief of staff or campaign
chairman,
the League as a menu of blood and Shimon
and body parts with Atlanta Alisha
Crowley event,
a private event.
Oh No,
I'm not talking about that.
I mean 200,000
plus dead Christians with her operation
with Syria and our operation in Libya
and not letting the Christians get out
and directing al Qaeda and isis who
target and murdered children and put
them through sex slavery and throw
Catholic priest off cliffs and kill
people and Mash and murder gauge and
everything else you can imagine because
they don't like peaceful people and they
caught him by the there for open society
and they love everybody.
Anything they do is for degradation
and someone could have been killed
inside of your restaurant for no good
reason.
People like Alex Jones Fan,
a conspiracy theory that even the DC
police say has no basis.
In fact,
yes,
it's a pack of lies and it's dangerous.
What happened to the boyfriend
to drive across four state lines with an
assault rifle and enter a family
friendly restaurant at 3:00
in the afternoon on a Sunday.
I know reddit has banned this topic on
its website.
I mean slowly but surely those who
helped fan it are trying to dial it back
out of the safety concerns for the
safety of those who have been endangered
by pis could happen to anyone.
It's not just us.
It's any single person.
I know you said there are producers.
It's also surreal until the gun comes
in.
Wow.
And then some guy for being here.
So they went.
They got it.
They didn't get it off youtube.
They got the full clap.
They cut the front off knowing.
I was actually saying,
I don't know about the satanism before
the term pizza gate was out there,
but I do know she's funded the radicals.
I came,
I saw they die.
He do rape and kill and cut up kids.
So she personally is.
You are making a very provocative
statement and you made it very
provocative statement by saying
something kind of crazy at first.
And then backing it up and so what they
decided to do is just edit a chunk of
that and so they didn't really have to
edit it and chop it up.
But they did take it,
take it out of context and said that I
was talking about.
Right.
But you weren't.
And I was talking about the spirit
cooking Alistair Crowley stuff with the
lady is written,
it's real for her.
And they go and I take little kids have
these parties and they have of blood.
That's one thing,
if you were an adult one to do that,
you know,
issue some art project.
This is real.
And so I was talking about the menu,
were there in the email saying,
you know,
we're going to have plenty of blood,
plenty of semen for you.
And other delicious things on the menu.
And he's like,
what are the juices on the menu?
And they go,
well we're going to have cheese pizza.
We're gonna have,
we're gonna have the,
the,
the nut sauce.
We're going to have the pasta and we're
going to have,
you know,
Shaquille and hot dogs.
We know you love sucking one hot dogs
and they go,
Oh God,
I want to go back to that place in a why
that had the best dogs,
you
know,
so yes,
we've got hot dogs and Obama wants
$65,000
or the hot dogs live with the party.
Will the hot dogs be there?
And then it's in Stratford and CII
emails that got leaked by wikileaks did.
Now people cross reference where the
CIA's like watching going,
oh look at Obama and Chicago,
another hot dog party.
Well did they momma is at a party with
15 dudes and that's his issue.
The point is though,
they can blackmail him with this and the
stuff.
We never got pedophile codes with Obama.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's men.
I mean he's had his mother trying to say
that Barack Obama is a homosexual.
Sandy's bisexual.
How dare you.
I really don't even care if you ever
seen him with a man.
How do you know this is true of seeding
with men walking down the street?
Maybe he just likes to bring dudes and
have conversations with them.
Maybe he just works hard to tell it to
people and you're the head of the free
world.
Maybe he had a party with $65,000
with the hot dogs.
Yeah,
maybe loves hot dogs.
He said,
fuck it.
Fuck this diet.
I'm not the president anymore filling.
Now listen,
I tried 65,000,
$65,000.
He's balling.
That's more of the 65,000
hot dogs.
What a gourmet hot does.
What a dollar apiece to color.
How many say it's super gourmet?
$5 a piece for each president needs a
hot dog helping hands.
What if it turns out he was like the 10
time hot dog eating champion.
He's like one of those.
That's probably it.
What does that say?
He probably.
Okay.
Let's say he just really likes hot dogs
here.
Alex Jones,
like there's a whole article on sale for
$65,000
for the hot dogs.
$5 a piece.
$5 per hotdog.
But listen,
you know,
you got to get those delivered.
Someone's gonna make.
I'm gonna.
Grind it up,
put it in the casing,
the whole deal.
Maybe he gets like gourmet hot dogs.
Got to put those kids putting together
some giant party.
Some I'm out of this job party.
I don't know,
but what a dog is a code for male
prostitutes.
Okay.
Maybe it is,
but what I'm saying is anybody who's
skeptical,
anybody who's looking at this and go,
and you guys are so fucking crazy.
This is so you're.
You're making such gigantic leaps of
faith.
No leaps.
Just looking on how with the weird code
in those emails,
there was definitely some code and show
after this one,
I'm in fact my crew actually got mad to
be honest with you,
but you tell her about the truth.
There were about five days into this and
the news hadn't even picked it up and
all my crew was doing all day reading
thousands of emails.
I mean there's thousands that are just
related to food and hot dogs and kids
and hot tubs and kid deliveries and all
and,
and.
Oh,
the spirit cooking and Alistair Crowley
and oh,
there'll be semen and blood.
I told my crew,
I said,
it's probably true.
No one's going to believe it.
Stop obsessing on it and stop reading
these emails because I want to focus on
the election and everything else that's
happening,
so then site start accusing me of
covering up the the pedesta stuff before
it's called pizza gate and then I get
blamed for being behind pizza gate and
I'm not even bitching.
I'm explaining what it's like to really
be trying to get at the truth and the
people take the fact that it's complex.
She'd be better at this to me.
Jokes,
you know how to put stuff out.
Clear and Parson I just know all this
crap,
but you get crazy and still ran.
People won't listen to me because I got
too
much data.
And you imagine what this is like.
I mean it's just.
I'm sick of it.
I don't know everything that's going on,
but I know this.
I have good CIA people and FBI and
secret service.
Okay.
Telling me.
Yes.
Alex.
it's worse than,
you know.
Keep getting them.
It's going to come out and it's starting
to come out and saying,
watch.
When we started arresting the pedophile
networks,
we're going to roll up the Democrats and
the Republicans that are involved,
and that's why trump said in his
speeches at the,
at the inaugural,
this is not about parties.
We're taking these people on.
We're bringing God back in.
Even somebody that wasn't very religious
like trump has gotten religion learning
about this because let me tell you
something.
Trump's not a devil worshiper and he
loves God and he's been briefed on all
this and he's going to roll their ass up
so the pedophiles better get ready.
I want to.
I want you to clear something up right
now.
Look at that camera and tell everybody
you're not bill Hicks.
So stupid to tell them you're not.
I'm not either tell them.
Well,
number one,
people think there's a god conspiracy.
Here's what happens.
They think it's a flat earth too.
I take real stuff.
Notice Joseph has researched,
not kissing his ass,
so he knows all these little points on
making better than I even did.
Yeah.
I'm like remembering stuff when he
brings it up,
because I try to suppress after is crap.
I can't handle it anymore,
man.
I'm 43 and I'm sitting here looking at
all this and that,
and these people come to you on the
street and they go,
hey joe,
hey,
Joe sent me five times and then I tried
like,
oh,
I knew you were.
You know,
we're,
we're not just telling us Alex,
whatever,
whatever.
My fucking name is the programming.
Say Bill Hicks.
Yeah,
I got no stress.
All they say,
here's the.
I'll be on the street or I'll be at a
restaurant and they come over and they
go.
They say,
hey bill,
hey bill.
Hey Bill.
They don't really show Rogan variously
and,
and I'm,
and I turned around and go,
oh,
I know what you all.
Because I did a few pieces and one
little video with a guy that lived in
Austin and the unit,
it's how I met with,
but you don't like Bill Hicks.
That's what's ridiculous about it.
Like what'd you get?
Like massive plastic surgery changed the
way your voice sounds like your voice is
so different than thing is that no one
ever wants to look real conspiracies
because they're complex and hard to
understand.
They want to just go with the earth is
flat.
Uh,
you know,
there's aliens living underneath the
capital.
Dinosaurs aren't real or.
Well,
no,
I mean,
listen,
the point is I'm not going to Bash
Eddie,
Eddie.
It's good to have a free open mind,
but he doesn't promulgate stuff.
He's only researching what's been said.
So I want to just get this out of the
way.
I am Bill Hicks.
I'm actually,
you are.
Hell,
we'll bill hicks be like 60.
Um,
I think he died at 32 and 1994.
So,
uh,
do the math.
I know one thing.
It's hot in here isn't really.
I don't know.
I always keep my studio really cold.
Oh,
do you?
Well,
you get crazy.
You're a goddamn fun.
Inferno.
A melting.
You know,
there's a lot of people that don't know
like how you got started,
but one of the things I thought was
really bizarre in that thing was that
lady was calling you a right wing host,
a far right wing host.
You've never been a right wing guy and
it's a.
it's a big misconception like you were
always totally anti Bush.
You've got arrested.
Speaking as actually before Bush was
even.
You were trying to stop him from being
elected back when Clinton was in,
when he stole the election from Gore,
who I didn't even really like.
I still came out and exposed it and it's
now been certified in Congress and
they've documented.
I just go with what the facts are,
but you've never been.
One of the things that really opened my
eyes.
This is a really important video that
you did nine slash 11 road to tyranny.
We talked about the World Trade
Organization protests and how they had
sent in these people in government
uniforms with government issue boots and
these anarchists.
They were dressed in black and they.
It's that this is an actual tactic that
they'll use to break up peaceful protest
will.
They'll send in soldiers or policeman or
whoever the hell they're hiring,
no one knows and they send these people
and they smash everything up.
They started to turn into a violent
protest and light things on fire and
then they all hold up in a building and
they negotiated their release and none
of them were ever arrested and when you
showed this clip by clip from these
various news organizations and you
focused on the kind of clothing they're
wearing and the difference in their
behavior versus the behavior of all the
peaceful protests,
and then show the result of it,
which had these people that were walking
to work with a WTO sticker that had a
line through it and police stopped them
and said,
you can't have that sticker on that book
bag.
You committed Beta test for martial law,
and again,
I'm not anti cops themselves.
The media always spins it.
You expose pedophilia.
They blamed to the pizza place.
You expose the government trying to make
cops do bad things.
Now you hate everybody.
Not even been comped,
I mean who knows who was doing the Delta
Force.
That makes sense.
Delta force and I'm blasting Delta
force.
They were given an order by Clinton to
go out and to recruit and they recruited
just about 400 leftist foundation funded
groups funded by big private
foundations.
They trained them for about a month
before in Oregon.
They flew them there,
put them in a government housing
facility.
This was on the newsletter.
I just covered local news story.
They did retreat to a building and
negotiated their surrender and they were
released.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But this was after all this property
damage.
They went out to start the attack,
so they had it on video so they could
then attack the hundred thousand
peaceful protesters.
So this was something that,
I mean we don't like.
We like to think just like you don't
like to think that pedophiles are real.
You don't like to think that anyone in
the government,
whatever,
organize some kind of an attack or some
sort of a,
a,
a fake event where a bunch of people
that you hire to start smashing things
to make a peaceful protest look bad.
We don't want to think that that's
possible,
but it is possible.
Goes on,
but it turns out that this is actually a
documented yet tactic.
Yes,
there was the WTO,
in fact,
esquire about two years ago,
was doing a profile on me and the guy,
his dad database,
a former CIA section chief and had been
involved a bunch of stuff himself and I
told him,
I said,
yeah,
Delta force ran those riots,
and he goes,
you're a liar.
And I said,
no,
I'm not.
He.
He went and googled it and couldn't
believe he got the Seattle Post
intelligence surge and stuff and then
even went and talked to a journalist
that knew because he'd been there
covering it as a journalist and he
didn't even know.
So he says in the esquire article,
okay,
Alex Jones got me there because even
though I'd grown up in the CIA and
stuff,
I don't know that was happening,
but,
but let's be clear,
it's criminal elements using
compartmentalization that do this.
They always claim I hate the government
and I want to have a war and all this
other stuff.
No,
I have to give credit to the good
elements of the CIA and the good
elements of the NSA.
I mean,
I'm good friends.
That's a very important point.
Very important point.
I've had this point with a friend of
mine when we were talking about,
um,
uh,
I've had Mike Baker on the podcast
before and through the few conversations
that I've had with Mike Baker is
formerly the CIA.
I get it.
You start getting an understanding of
how it works.
Like these drug dealings that always
kinda like jets crashing with all the
coke on board.
They're cowboys.
You got like a few dudes,
God's run inside sideshows few dudes who
realize they can make a fuck load of
money if they sell.
And there might be a lot of people
involved,
but it's not the whole CIA.
It's not like they have government memos
on.
It.
Will do is they'll have a cover and
option they're running.
The president says do this.
Like Ronald Reagan didn't know about the
cocaine dealing.
I've talked to folks that were involved
actually for the points.
He says,
I want conesh knocked out congress.
That'll give them the funding.
They go,
well you do in the government is you go,
the president said,
do this.
We're we're men of action.
We're going to do it.
So then there's cocaine already being
sold.
The contracts are using it to get all
their funding will screw that.
We'll just jacket bring it in using
private contractors.
And that wasn't the first time they did
it for Vietnam.
Vietnam too.
But yeah,
it was a.
It was a common tactic.
They knew that there was money that was
being made from selling illegal drugs.
Why would they let that money be made
all around them?
They're not going to.
That's the argument is you don't want to
let the communist do all the cocaine and
heroin dealing or the kids,
then they have more money than you.
Well,
what the fuck is going on in
Afghanistan?
It's just this crazy people.
How much heroin production went up since
our occupation?
Anybody can pull this up again.
That's what's frustrating is a lot of
the fake liberals because I see myself
as a real liberal,
but a lot of the fake liberals just go,
oh,
that's a lot of this is like,
no,
you can search engine opium production
in Afghanistan pre 2001 and then look at
the latest years.
It's come out in like 2014,
15.
It went from three percent of world
supply to seven percent.
The 30 percent and after 10 years of
occupation it went to 93 percent.
Look at mobile supply.
So look at the heck Taylor went from a,
a memory will,
was I right?
Well,
there were.
It's pretty substantial increase between
2001,
which is at an all time low on this
chart from 94 to 2016.
So 2000,
one's an all time low and then the next
year it fucking skyrocket,
but Google and BBC and ap just type in
Afghanistan,
90 plus percent world opium production.
It's very,
very hot.
Ninety three percent and listened and
also for like opiate pills or is it just
for Jews for everything.
So it's not like oxycontin's and things
along those lines that they ordered the
trips to the Taliban that works with
them was allowed to grow it and then
they're allowed to sell it to whoever
wants to buy it.
Well,
not just that
there's been documented,
confirm instances of troops that are
being forced to guard poppy field.
Sure.
We'll,
we'll let me break it down for it.
Right when the shorter commitments on
Fox News with Geraldo Rivera,
remember that shareable that came out a
year after I broke it again.
Let me tell you how they work.
It comes out that the trips are being
ordered right there.
It goes.
Ninety percent of the world's supply of
opm according to the United Nations and
hit 93 last year.
What?
How many years old is this?
A couple of years.
Like three years old,
two years old.
Say It's gone from 93 right now.
Jesus Christ.
See I didn't lie.
I said 93 and it's not for this.
Yeah.
So,
but it.
That's what's so frustrating is you know
all this and then.
And then people still call you crazy.
Now what Alex,
why do explain the fake news cyop why do
a lot of people out there think info
wars is total fake news?
Why do they think that?
That is a major deep state government
program funded by Soros mainly and they
found the most effective way is anti
Israel bashing and so this came out in
the Wiki leaks last year.
The US intelligence sleep,
not the Russians that he's in there
saying,
we're going to overthrow Israel.
We've got to deal with Saudi Arabia and
we've got to up the ante with anti
Israel rhetoric.
I'm somebody that was neutral in Israel.
Never been there,
had nothing to do with it.
Israel has liberals,
conservatives,
some good administration,
some bad,
but I'm not anti Israel.
It's a tiny little place.
I know it does some things that are bad
compared to what we've done.
It's nothing,
so I just don't have some giant hard on
for Israel,
you know,
wanting to hurt him and,
and,
and I'm not against the Palestinians or
anybody else.
Everybody knows that show show when they
killed Israelis from the reason I say
it's wrong when they white phosphorous
bomb Palestinians,
I say it's wrong.
Show.
I'm sitting there covering all that and
then they just put out that I'm this
Israeli agent,
you know,
all day long,
or I'm the CIA.
Let's not get into these crazy rants
about crazy accusations is why do they
think info wars wars is fake news.
I don't know you that a lot of people
out there,
smart people,
really intelligent.
They have.
They think the real news is CNN.
Okay,
well let me explain.
You've got attached from below and
above.
You've got major funding by Soros and
others.
There's a real life Nazi collaborator,
like true Dr.
Evil of the latest James Bond was based
on his real accompany.
It's even named after his company.
You don't like the bad guy in the movie.
He actually Soros,
yeah,
he tried to crash the pound breakdown
angle and he's really bad nose,
so [inaudible] 18,
but long story short about George Soros,
he's funding this attack on me and any
independent media.
How do you attack independent media when
the public's awake?
The deep state and government stuff.
You say Alex Jones is the government and
then they always ignore real facts.
I talk about her.
I admit some of my family and stuff
that's worked for the government and
they said the carpet was corrupted out
of control.
That isn't even a real debate but.
But above that.
What was your other question?
He had a with question was.
Explain the Sol.
Andy,
let me.
Let me just explain.
It's pretty easy.
Did their indirect competition with him?
If it's Fox News,
if it's CNN,
if it's anybody that's distributing
news,
you're in direct competition with
someone who has an independent news
organization.
They operate it themselves and
they do it online.
Show just said it perfectly.
That's it.
Alex is in a very unusual position
because he's a magnet people to people
who are drawn to him like a lightening
Rod.
He says a lot of crazy shit.
He goes on rants.
He's very animated.
He's fun to watch and a lot of this
shit.
He says this correct and we're getting
into this right now like this.
This thing about the WTO,
which was like I said,
was one of the first ones that really
opened up my eyes.
That was a long time ago too.
That was like you put that video out in
2002 or something like when was that?
Two thousand three.
It was like 2011 right after nine slash
11 right after September 11th and put it
on the web router if that.
Exactly.
I put it out on DVD or something up
before that.
But you just said it joke.
So let me try to actually thinking
codified this then because my problem is
I don't script what I say or that it's
kind of all over the map,
which is a good thing or a bad thing.
You just did it on the head.
You ask your question why they call me
fake news.
We just saw Megan Kelly two weeks before
the election,
say in a whole hour long show,
special against fake news.
We've played a few minutes of it.
Alex Jones is the king of fake nose.
He just said Hillary is chopping up
children inside of basement at a pizza
place.
Now,
granted,
I was saying it in satire about her in
the Middle East,
so it begged for them to take it out of
context,
but they clearly did that to deceive
their viewers.
She's branding herself.
I'm real.
You can trust me.
Look at this.
Poor victim,
Alex Jones almost got him killed when
none of it was true when none of it was,
you're based in reality.
And what I,
what I was getting was from the NYP ed.
Okay.
And the FBI,
who are good people are at least those
agents show.
There's an example of them branding,
texting it in.
They'll take something real life said.
Or they've taken videos where I'm acting
stupid.
Uh,
you know,
with like five x six x underwear,
it,
if they're given the illegals or
whatever.
And they'll show them with underwear on
my head and say,
look,
this guy's crazy and I get it.
I cover serious topics so they can take
it out of context.
But when I'm being serious,
which is 90 percent of the time I tell
people,
but when joe comes in and we've got
joey,
Joey,
now,
Joey Diaz talking about kidnapping
people,
I start laughing or whatever.
Yeah,
we had fun.
Look,
you're a normal person and that's a.
that's what people find hard to believe.
When I tell people I'm friends with Alex
Jones,
they go,
get the fuck out of here.
You're Casey.
Great Guy.
We have a good time together.
We were very nice show.
You're a great guy.
I switched when we aren't also busy and
hang out more like I'm the oldest.
I know.
Well,
we can do it.
I'm going to come back to Austin.
I'm trying to get to Austin probably the
spring trying to figure out when and
when and where I'm going to get.
But uh,
I love Austin where you live as a
fucking beautiful place.
Well,
I know these topics can be,
you know,
quite frankly exhausting.
They are,
they are,
but,
but I'd like to shove today really get
into the big picture and what I believe
is really going on because I figured out
the basis of what's happening and I'm
going to let you,
I mean if you wanna hear some far out
stuff today,
I think because what you experienced,
I mean,
I'll go through it.
Okay,
let's go.
let me take a piss then.
Good.
Because Joe's always so slick and
columns.
So are you,
Eddie,
me,
I get in here and I just got another
round.
We're going to bring you down.
We're going to bring you down to earth
every now and then you're going to
launch into orbit.
We're going to grab you by your heels,
bring
it back.
We're going to be fine.
We'll get through this.
Go take a piss and then tell some crazy
shit.
Where's the bathroom?
Right through that door to the right.
Powerful alerts.
Drones so far,
Eddie,
Bravo.
Everything you wanted and more.
Oh,
absolutely.
I'm just sitting here letting them just
letting,
letting the people,
letting your fans know that have never
listened to him.
I listened to Alex Jones every goddamn
day and she'd take a day off every now
and then.
Otherwise you'd be like,
fuck bloom.
Um,
but he's a good guy.
You know,
he's always been a good guy.
People that don't listen to them,
they,
they believe what the mainstream media
has said about us,
but it's also he makes it easy for them
by saying crazy shit.
Like Hillary Clinton chops up babies and
all that stuff and I know he's doing it
for dramatic effect and it's one of the
reasons why show is so popular because
he does a lot of things like that.
It makes it easy for people to dismiss
them.
And then you get into this thing where,
okay,
let's,
before you dismiss them,
let's look at what he said.
What is.
He said that's true.
And they look at what he said.
Everything you said today so far,
so far,
everything that he said,
it's just like his radio show.
He doesn't have any teleprompters.
This dude can talk for forever.
That's a thing though,
when you wind up doing a lot of
podcasts,
especially doing these radio shows,
shows like Alex says by himself,
we just ranting rants and rents for long
periods of time.
You develop like a certain muscle,
like there's a lot of guys who do their
own pod,
like bill burr is a perfect example,
does his own podcast by himself all the
time and he's got this ability to go
just rant from one subject to the next
subject and keep going.
And when you have a podcast it's just,
you just kinda gotta get out of his way.
So with Alex you just kinda gotta feed
them.
Some subjects get out of his way,
but every now and then he does so many
subjects in a row.
I got to bring them back.
I gotta go,
you gotTa.
Okay,
let's get to this one.
How did she steal estates?
You just can't gloss over that.
Let's get to this.
Okay,
let's get to it.
Broke it down per.
He did a great job.
Yeah,
and this is a.
I think this is going to help people
have just seeing Alex like this is going
to help people have a chance to look at
this whole picture of just forget about
where your loyalties lie,
whether you enjoy CNN or Fox News or
whatever,
to just sit outside of it right now and
look at what it really is because what
it really is is why is anyone want to
give you the news?
Are they giving you the news because
they love you or are they giving you the
news because it's a program and they're
trying to make money and do they have
access to certain people because they're
willing to play certain games.
Most likely when you're looking at
something that's on a major league
television show,
whether it's Fox News or NBC or CBS or
whatever the fuck it is,
you had to go through some serious
channels to get there.
If you're a guy with a suit and a tie,
good evening America and you're doing
that guy,
that guy on any of those major networks,
you've had to go through some fucking
serious hoops and ladders and checks and
balances.
You got to represent something in order
to be the person who reads the news,
but what is that news for?
Is it a fucking show
or is it really the news?
Are they really trying to help you?
What are they trying to do with?
Why?
Why are they doing the news?
Are they doing it because they love you
and care for you and they want you to be
informed or they're doing it because
they're clearly biased and they've got
an agenda?
Well,
if you watch Fox News and then CNN just
go back and forth whenever there's
something going on.
Like how I did it after the election,
I was like,
Fox News,
CNN,
CNN.
It's who the fuck is telling the truth.
Someone's gotta be lying.
Why don't you Fox is lying.
One of you is line because there's one
story over here and it's a totally
different story over here,
so all you need to know,
just looking at that,
just forget about what you are,
whether you're a progressive liberal,
whether you're a conservative
Republican.
Just look at that and understand that
you're getting all of your information
from these sources that have a vested
interest in relaying their particular
version of the truth.
That's not good for anybody that
represents the party.
The party like Fox is totally get me one
no matter what kid.
Dude,
come on.
Get one for Eddie Bravo to.
Let's get crazy.
You bring out the hatchets.
I hope that people listen to your show.
The people that have never given them
was a little nervous.
I want to get going for was just do it.
Bring out the whiskey all I want.
Like for me,
I don't want to be this conspiracy guy
making money and doing shows.
I walked away from my podcast.
I was talking about conspiracies.
I really don't want to be that
conspiracy guy,
but something inside me,
uh,
is,
wants to wake people up.
That's all I'm trying to do.
That's all I'm trying to.
I'm trying to help.
I'm not making money off any conspiracy
theories or anything.
I tell myself every time I walk in here,
don't say shit about conspiracies.
Whiskeys going to bring it out of him,
Bro.
You know what I'm saying here when there
was a big fan of yet.
Oh cool.
He said he wants to roll with you later.
Oh Shit.
Back Surgery.
So you said so he said so you can kick
his ass.
Know Eddie just had a desk replaced.
It's finally time to meet with the CIO,
but every now and then don't you want to
be like on that side and just have half
full access?
They don't see.
I don't hold that whiskey hostile.
Alex Jones.
Alright listen,
let me give you guys the big fricking
data.
I'm willing to give it to them.
Okay.
I mean I'm not bullshitting.
I got the thing.
Figure it out.
Pour one for Eddie.
I got to figure it out guys.
If you want.
I mean I'll pour a little.
Alright gentlemen.
Cheers.
I'm going to keep my mouth cheers to
you.
Alex Jones.
Here's a good buddy.
Stuff.
People were so on one side or the other
when it comes to this.
There's so much anticipation regarding
the.
So much bullying.
Don't have Alex Jones on it,
but there was a lot of that.
There's a lot of where you're going to
call him on his racist shit.
Someone said that to me,
Alex Jones is one of the least racist
people you'll ever meet in your life.
I've never even heard you say a racial
thing.
Race is so inconsequential to you.
I'm in what you think and what they
stand for.
You have never discussed race ever in
the almost.
What do I know you 16 fucking 17 years.
I've never heard you discuss race at
all,
so someone calling you a racist,
like
what?
You just all they do all trump's waving
a rainbow flag and say he's a homophobe.
There was a guy walking next to me in
New York.
I was there after the election.
I was there for the UFC.
It was right after the election and me
and my friend campaigns are walking back
from the gym.
We walked,
we went over to the gym,
we're walking back.
We walked right into the fucking protest
and there was this guy that was standing
next to me screaming,
Donald Trump KKK,
racist,
sexist.
They had tied gay,
gay,
Gay,
racist,
sexist,
anti gay.
He just kept screaming it out as Donald
Trump's in the KKK is if John will
trump,
are you sure he's racist?
Are you sure there's any discrimination
hires?
Gay guys are running casinos and hotels
and is friends with them and like gave
interviews with the advocate 20 years
ago.
It's all just complete.
Made up horse crap.
He's waving a rainbow flag at the RNC
speech.
He says,
Republicans have to stop being mean to
gay people and have to be inclusive and
he's about to enforce civil rights laws
for gays and others and they're calling
him a literal homophobe.
Then listen all it says my problem
upside down,
bs man visit,
but this is my problem with it.
My problem with it is that people want
to use a real.
You're a bigot.
You're this,
you're that.
They want to come up with a nice quick
label that officially makes them,
but make sure that it boxes usually
finds you and then you have to defend
yourself.
Look,
you said it best at the beginning of
this.
Donald trump is not perfect.
He's a man and he's also a super
ambitious,
super wealthy man.
It's constantly on the go and those
kinds of dudes are type a hyper
aggressive personalities and he's
definitely said some shit he shouldn't
have said,
right?
I mean,
don't you agree?
Like third we'll do this.
The big one is one that he said in
confidence with that billy Bush guy,
the grab 'em by the pussy thing.
That's the big one.
Who has it in confidence,
especially if you're famous,
said,
man,
it's crazy.
Women throw themselves on you.
You can do anything you want.
Sexual assault,
a woman's climbing up on top of you.
You can do whatever you want.
That's what mammals do.
She's showing she wants it.
She gets it.
A sexual assault.
It's pure horse crap.
Instead of a woman's said,
yeah,
I just,
I could just see it in their eyes.
I could just go up and grab them in the
balls.
We wouldn't.
We wouldn't allow for fucking Briana.
Briana just talked about how she can
fuck any got.
She wants just walks up to him,
grabs by the deck.
We will be like total.
We would think it's amazing.
I started about group is he wasn't
talking about that he hides behind
bushes and reds for joggers reaches out
and context out of context.
He's having a guy conversation,
right?
Like he described it as locker room with
the recorder,
but I know I got this and this is not
defending it.
I mean,
it's definitely not something you should
have said probably.
Right.
We could all agree to that,
but what is he really doing?
He's really what we call talk and shit
like Eddie Talk Shit so much to each of
the laughing saying things we totally
don't believe.
We totally don't mean,
but we're trying to make each other
eventually.
We're Lee.
Eddie and I are silly all the time.
You had a transcript of all the
conversations.
You and I have had a fucking 17 years.
We've been friends.
Oh Shit.
We'd be in trouble.
Can't put it on air.
We'd be in fucking real trouble.
Real content on facebook mentions into
that live video.
You doesn't mean.
It's so funny watching the stupid TV
show.
Oh my God.
That show was awesome and then as soon
as I turned the camera on,
you wouldn't say all that stuff,
but it wasn't.
None of it was bad,
but it was like off the cuff weren't,
you know,
you weren't censoring while I forgot
what I said to a lot of marijuana
involved in this conversation.
Go on forever.
Jesus.
I'll put these off.
You don't like them.
You don't have to wear it so loud.
You don't have to worry about it.
Alex Jones,
who's here.
Seriously,
I just want to do a good job and
actually reached out to your 100 and 110
million.
Who knows how many downloads a month?
20 million on Youtube.
All the derivatives and everything else
you're doing and I hear you sometimes on
Xm.
He still doing that?
No,
no,
I'm not on the XML.
Whatever the point is is that you're one
of the biggest shows in the world.
Let me give you a newsflash,
not for your ego.
Okay,
but you need to know this.
I don't see that as a signal to the
mainstream media of apathetic.
They are in top show has maybe a million
viewers there.
Average show about 100,000.
Fox was top show,
maybe 4 million to nine on a bigger
night.
Okay,
great.
Good for them.
I'm not in competition with them.
The point is there a freaking joke.
I conservatively,
everyday on terrestrial radio have $4
million listeners on my 200 plus
stations.
That's rated proven.
I mean that's big right there and then
millions and millions of downloads every
day.
Tens of millions of people watching the
videos.
You've added all together 40 something
million a week.
We go back to this.
What's happening?
It isn't about Joe Rogan or Alex Jones
Ready,
Bravo or any of that.
It's about the people are hungry for
being able to have a wider selection of
things.
When you and I are totally different
categories because all I'm trying to do
is give them interesting content.
You're actually trying to run a new show
and expose to some really smart
commentary.
I'll watch clips all the time.
I have people on all the time.
It's just you try to open minds all the
time,
open mind the different way.
I meant to say that what I'm not,
I'm not honestly not trying to open
minds,
I'm being curious and I'm asking
questions and I'm trying to learn as
much myself and then once I do learn
about things,
I would like to have that person come on
to teach other people about it because I
think it's interesting.
Well,
here's the big Enchilada for folks.
If you want to lay the sound Chilada
documentary down the road and actually
break this down,
but there is a whole breakaway
civilization and I'm listening to Ufo
getting ready.
I don't ever talk about this for real
breakaway civilization.
Are you ready?
Hold on.
Joe.
How many things that I tell you over the
years?
Too many to many.
That came true.
That was a couple that you got wrong.
You can't get them all right.
Which one?
Two K people.
The context.
My list from that explained the white.
It's okay.
A conspiracy theory.
It's just not trusting criminals.
Every now and then you can in that
murder to the criminal,
but he still a criminal even though
you're wrong.
Well,
one of the things that I'm actually
embarrassed about is the y two k.
oh,
well,
hey listen,
you're not a consumer.
You're not a computer expert.
Near My.
I didn't go anywhere that night.
I stayed home and I was waiting for that
God damn power to go out,
have some big news in a minute,
but since any rather than 12,
I didn't know.
I thought damn the Mayans.
No,
we thought it was over.
I didn't think that any problem.
And I was convinced 200,012
licensed to December 2012 licensed.
I did.
Oh,
just tobacco.
Yes.
Very strong tobacco from Mexico.
Oh,
sorry.
I'm in California.
This is for medical reason.
Hundred 100 percent medical reasons and
legal.
Um,
yeah,
I mean there's still,
there's a lot of things if people think
are going to happen that turned out to
not happen.
There's always a goddamn asteroid.
It's going to kill us all.
That doesn't actually.
It's important to not inhale.
So what?
What is going on?
Aliens are coming.
Let me hear it.
Let me,
before I do this,
let me answer his question because he
got it.
Reagan question to,
well,
let me answer y two k because I want to
be bit honest about this.
This was one of the few things that debt
I have really gotten wrong and I didn't
go with my gut and so I was proven wrong
and I did it for the wrong reason.
So now I'm going to actually confess,
your honor,
I was on one radio station.
I've been on TV for a few years.
I was on one radio station already
started to show it to my house that was
on like 15 radio stations,
so I had that at least,
but I was on one big radio station,
had the top show at night station with
Howard stern was killer,
was all over the newspaper,
had huge ratings and I was bringing in
like,
you know,
20,
30 grand a month,
which was just a huge amount for me.
Building whole operation out of that at
home.
And they come to the sales guys and they
go look for a year.
You've not been behind y twoK and you're
not letting us have all these big
sponsors and you're gonna basically be
fired if you don't let us endorse these
sponsors and have them on errands.
Say You believe in y two k hold on a
second.
So these sponsors were like doomsday
stuff like canned food and shit and
bunkers.
Everything else.
So stacy wants to make all this money so
the station made you push y two k y.
But let me go further.
This is one of the few times in my life
that I don't want to say I didn't have
integrity.
I kinda let them convince me.
But I think back to the point in the
conference room I just Kinda went okay,
okay,
sure.
I get it.
And then I went.
And then once I decided it was true,
I really pushed it.
So it's almost like I lied to myself yet
because I'm being honest about this
process.
So.
So this is what happened for like a year
and a half.
I'm saying it's bs,
it's a government hoax because they're
like,
the navy says the chips are all bad and
54 cities will completely fall and it's
all the death.
And I said they just want to upgrade
with all this new spy hubs and when a
new global standardization for the US,
it's the telecommunications act of
[inaudible] 96,
they want to force all the new chips
because I had an NSA sources that I was
having on.
Okay.
And I didn't realize how special it was
that I had these sources and they're
telling me it's all bs people.
I don't argue with the navy and don't.
Art and Fox News had ads to get your
food.
It was just everywhere.
Someone kill.
Okay,
stuff's going to be real.
So it's like a black Friday for black
Friday sale.
So the last few months and the moral was
they ended up firing me anyways.
They did.
But the moral was,
I kind of convinced myself it was real.
So by the end of it,
and of course they edit it like,
you know,
12 hours and beyond that day,
like five minutes.
I'm totally insane.
But it's like nuclear reactor having a
problem here and it really was happening
and like,
you know,
oh,
and there was a missile fired from
Russia which was an icbm and they got
shot down.
That was ABC News.
So I'm like,
alright,
this isn't really happening.
Okay.
Know we got prepared.
It's always good to prepare,
but hopefully I'll get a reactor is
having a problem.
Okay.
Some stuff's that.
There was some outages and problems,
but government and MSM had hyped it.
Then they used it to demonize
alternative media.
Even then when it wasn't catastrophic.
So my gut told me it was bs.
It was bs.
And so thank God I missed the whole 2012
thing.
But still they said,
Alex Jones says the world's ending the
bureau 2012 where he really starts when
I say it's all a load of crap,
but I didn't criticize you when I saw
you doing it.
I said I was balls deep.
And here's the thing.
It wasn't,
it was the listers.
They were pissed at me that I wouldn't
go into this thing.
But it's fun for them.
See,
when you start talking about the end of
the world are doomsday come and people
like that shit because it gives them
something to think about,
but I guess here's a lot of people out
future you.
It was a long time ago,
17 years ago,
right?
Y,
twoK ,
17 fucking years ago at least 2012.
Didn't get you redeemed yourself.
You can think about 17 years ago.
That's a long time ago.
I mean in you getting fired from that
job.
Every great radio guys gotten fired.
You Howard stern got fired.
You got fired like public loves,
but it was just like Howard stern fire
man,
top ratings,
and they were all pissed and weird about
it.
The weird thing is they didn't mess with
the losers.
They were all flipping out because I was
getting the big paychecks.
Well,
it makes sense.
It was the same day and the y two k
thing totally makes sense that they
would want you to really push that and
sell it hard because he the fuck the
hoes,
you know,
we don't know.
You get scared.
You're like,
well,
the navy says it's going to happen in
Washington Post now your listers are
real,
and it was the one time I went,
oh,
okay,
maybe I'll go do it.
I had people on there were telling me
there was something that was going to
happen on 2012.
They were sure of it.
Yeah,
not a bullied by doing it.
You started stampeding like limits.
I'm telling you this,
a psychological going on,
just massive double crossing because I
really used to be in the Ufos,
but the more you look into the Ufo is it
looks like,
and that's another conspiracy.
Looks like the government NASA deal.
And when he came into the meeting he
couldn't do it.
I knew this guy well and then the next
time he was going to meet with me,
he.
His heart blew up.
It blew up.
Yeah,
like a bomb.
They said his heart completely ruptured.
Well,
the point is,
his name was Raymond t and if you look
at mission control,
he was the main guy as you control the
control,
the cameras and everything.
And he,
he was house.
He had national security letters from
the president.
He'd run like secret operations in
Cambodia and Laos.
He was an air force engineer and uh,
he,
he knew the whole deal and he would say,
what whole day would you say to meet
with you and tell you everything?
And he would
come and start gulping and he couldn't
get it out,
couldn't get one out.
He said he was so threatened or
whatever.
He couldn't tell me about you think
about it.
He probably,
he probably left and he was in the car.
Raymond was telling me a lot.
He said,
Alex,
your sources are right.
There were advanced technologies.
We were worried the astronauts might
die.
They had two teams in orbit.
One would the real ships.
This is not a joke,
Joe.
Wait a minute.
They had one wheel pose in an orbit and
they were communicating with Kennedy and
the government.
Everybody and Nixon are gonna have this
giant thing about Americans,
number one and not have a backup plan of
the astronauts die.
Uh,
put those headphones back on and lost
your fucking mind,
Scott,
you into a corner.
Hold on,
let him finish there.
So tell me what you're trying to say.
Are you trying to say that?
So the United States government cheek
was going to give me the secret of NASA.
Okay.
And then he couldn't ever get it out.
He would get an order.
Now the second program,
they had a second program,
but how do you know he died?
And he told me before the heart attack
in the middle of the hard time second.
No,
no.
I met with him at the old sat command
base.
What did he actually tell you for work
or not?
What?
What He.
He told me.
He said you're,
you said from your analysis,
your sources.
You're dead on.
I was in control of the video and radio
communications and he was the Yoda Gvs.
Watch him on TV.
I mean it's very important that guy
controlling the Canada mission control
the two backups behind that.
Are you kidding?
Of course.
The,
the moon landings.
Are you kidding?
Come on.
Well,
you raised it.
You want them to know.
Oh,
come on.
That's ridiculous.
No,
but that's why I don't trust the
government.
That's why I don't trust it because they
ran,
they didn't want to spend money,
they ran a fake cop was just reentry
devices and basic stuff in space and did
shoot some of it,
but then they had a real mission that
put the reflectors,
everything on the moon.
We went to the moon.
But there's no proof of that.
So you believe.
Well,
you know that the uh,
the Russian government with the secret
space program,
Alex,
you know that the Russian government,
you know that the Russian government put
those lasers sight,
those laser reflectors on the moon as
well with unmanned probes.
Yes.
You know that right now there's still
Chinese.
The Chinese have a bunch.
So that's not like the,
there's,
there's weird evidence.
He went to them things that far away.
Just kidding.
Are you kidding?
This Alex,
you think they definitely went to the
moon?
They're just.
The footage is fake.
Is that what she thinks?
You can't bring film back to the Van
Allen Radiation Belt to get spots all
over it,
but we don't have film.
What would lead us to believe that they
definitely did it because they had rca
cameras.
There was interest on the amazing
footage,
right?
Does amazing footage launch in space in
case the real mission died.
So who's in the fake loan should show
you the real deal.
What happened?
Is there anything?
US military is in advance.
Okay.
But let's let him go.
Let him answer this.
Heady.
So we gotta you got to figure this out.
So what you're saying is the one that we
saw on TV with Neil Armstrong,
one small step for man,
that's all horse shit.
But the real one actually took place.
They just couldn't get the film back.
But Armstrong had been on real missions.
So yes,
he definitely been unreal missions but
had.
No,
no,
he wouldn't tell me all of it.
He died before we met.
The other dude was out on him the next
day and his wife called my dad was
friends with him.
They said,
no,
no.
The other guy.
What's his name?
Buzz Aldrin.
I do no buzz Aldrin.
Buzz Aldrin said,
I want to come on your show and I and I,
I'm not gonna get into all that heat.
Oh know he lives here in La and one time
I ran into them but I'll just leave it
at that and he said,
I want to come on your show.
I said,
all right,
well come on.
It's the only interview he said,
and he goes,
I'm going to tell you Alex,
your audience alone.
He said there is an envelope just like
2001.
It's on the Moon of Mars,
the moon and it sending a transmission
and it's all real and it's all Egypt and
there's aliens and everything else and
it's the only time he ever said it.
What?
Is there a clip of that pull up?
Buzz Aldrin up.
Pull that clip.
Dude.
It was online.
ABC News the next day.
So you see that.
Do you think he was fucking with him?
Do you think he's fucking with you know,
he was real.
He's a feisty fella.
I think he's full of Shit.
Why do you think he's full of Shit?
What if it's true?
He imagined there is an obelisk on Mars.
I think that's really is communicating
with an obelisk on the moon and Mars.
The Moon of Mars Phobos is that we got
to land there.
Did have been seen as instagram,
but that was a good lot of bitches.
Amazing boats to follow him.
Poaches and bitches and boats.
He's just like,
he's this.
Okay,
well let's take it.
Let's give some loving instagram.
Let's give some
with their habitation.
We can keep track if there's something
very important to be developed from the
moon.
I'm not sure what it is right now.
Of course you don't.
Sure.
Thanks.
Should identify it for.
Well,
the truth.
No,
no,
no.
I want to hear what he's doing here
about.
I want to hear,
but I want to hear what he says first.
Let's see what he says.
Hold it.
Go ahead.
Jamie.
America.
To make such gross expenditures again
for human habitation on a boat,
we can help.
We can join with together.
We can explore the moon and develop the
movement.
Still.
Tax Money.
Go do it together.
Oh,
Bill Shan has not gone before this where
he talks about that we need to go to a
monolith there.
A very unusual structure,
little potato shaped object.
We need $4,000,000
to in seven hours.
Find out about that.
They're going to say,
who put that there?
Who put that there?
Well,
the universe put it there.
If you choose combine and put it there.
Come on
wants $4,000,000,000.
Oh my God.
So that's the monolith.
That thing that you're looking at at.
Wow.
That's weird.
I don't believe that shit for a second.
Let me tell you about Buzz Aldrin here
in Los Angeles and I can't tell you
anything else.
Okay.
Look at this monolith on Phobos.
Weird.
Yeah.
That's took a weird structure.
Who knows?
That's a real picture.
That's all bullshit.
It's all bullshit.
Come on.
Yeah,
that,
that proves it.
Planes are all bullshit.
I can.
I don't know shit about photoshop and I
can make that.
I'm sure you can.
I tell you the big secret about my
secret meeting with me here.
The shitty fed.
You let me know.
Eddie don't sign.
Let's go ahead and let him communicate.
He told me that Papa SMURF has for you.
I'll show you what he told me.
He told me,
he said,
you know India is sending a probe to the
moon and they'll announce that when they
crashed the probe,
they found the undersea frozen ice that
covers the moon.
The moon has dust on it.
It's a big water bowl.
It's gonna be the water we need to get
off the planet.
We make our big jump.
So the whole point is,
suppose everything's laid on the planet
just perfect for humanity.
We make the steps right,
but it's like a video game.
Puzzle and highlight.
Fuck,
Buzz Aldrin.
No,
you're not listening.
He's fucking crash.
The proud found exactly what they were
saying and I'm walking through an
airport or later to look over and it
says,
it says India discovers water on the
moon and it's all water.
Well,
they've definitely discovered water on
the moon.
Right?
That's what they told me about it a year
before he sat.
Right?
Am I correct in saying there's no water
in the moment saying Buzz Aldrin?
Is he going to the meetings and they
tell them shit.
Listen,
he.
Yeah,
he went to the moon.
You want to get to go to every meeting.
I don't get into all this stuff.
I'm telling you.
Was older told me in a year it's going
to be on the news that they discovered
water with a probe or setting before
they were even sending a probe in the
news.
They left India quote,
find it because the US already found it.
It's already been on the moon.
God knows how many times the word is.
They got military bases on the other
side.
Alex was in the fifties.
What do you think we got now?
So you think they have new?
Wait a minute.
They have bases on the moon.
Well,
I don't ever get into all of this stuff,
right?
Don't do that.
But let's just say it's super advanced.
You really think that they have some
sort of a base out there and he's like,
I told you one,
a key word that's so far away.
Why wouldn't they just do it in a desert
somewhere?
What is this?
Am I p detected water on the moon way
back in June.
Huh?
It dropping dissemble on you,
Alex.
let me.
Buzz Aldrin tells me they're gonna.
Announce India finds water.
Oh my God.
Follow him on instagram and then come
back to me with some bizarre probe with
Buzz Aldrin.
Me.
Look at this.
The moon impact probe.
Which class crashed,
landed at a designated site on the lunar
South Pole on November 14,
2008.
I had picked up some clear signatures of
water during the five minutes to say
crash it.
Yeah.
Mr.
Nair said at a press conference here on
Friday.
Interesting when it comes to space,
Alex.
um,
uh,
that's not your forte.
I.
But one,
one thing I wanted to ask both alcorn
this time I want to shit on instagram
and then come back at me with his
instagram.
What's up with bottles?
It's amazing.
He's just like,
he's a,
he's slow.
He's so into it.
She,
when the guy comes over,
he goes,
you're full of crap.
You ever went to the money?
Just punches him.
Hey,
check this out.
I wanted to ask you,
what do you.
What do you think is trump going to do
anything about the stratospheric aerosol
injection?
I write that down because we were
talking about stratospheric aerosol
injection.
Can't get to the points that you want.
Let me know.
What do you think trump wants to stop
that.
I'm going to chuck write it down.
Write that down,
but the next question,
I'll do it here.
That's the question.
The question he just said was five
before the Alex Jones is off the rails
right now,
but I didn't get the job.
Why don't we have to write it down?
I didn't get it because you've been bad
listening.
Will trump.
Is trump going to do anything about
that,
that program to stop,
but what do you.
What do you think the program is ending?
What do you think the program,
the director of the CIA,
he's talking about it on Youtube.
Look on your job,
John.
Oh,
Brenda.
Talk about strategies,
strategies,
solid injections.
It's going to cost $10,000,000,000
a year and there's going to be some
countries opposed to it because it's
going to mess up the atmospheric
manipulation and I'm talking about
stratospheric.
I've never heard of that.
It's super important when you can break
it down to three letters yet.
Let's go to John.
Oh,
Brennan admitted last in June of 2016 at
the video and comment on it.
Can you play a jamie?
John O'Brien talking about this forever.
I'm not.
I'm not bashing you,
but you entertaining show my jokes about
it,
which I get because a lot of it's.
Yes,
there is an entire atmospheric
terraforming geoengineering
manipulation.
I don't call it chem trails and of
course the CIA director admitted.
They have this huge program.
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation owns
the major patents on it from
Westinghouse and others.
They use these big antennas to
manipulate the weather.
They can.
China's like causing huge harp like
technology.
It's all declassified.
Think heart manipulates the.
Whether they admit it does.
I used to have the hand of Heart,
general bitten k part.
Not all the time,
but the.
Exactly.
There's giant weather modification
systems and there's weather wars between
different governments and they.
It's all declasse.
Explain to people that are listening,
what harp is,
what does it stand for?
High altitude something.
Yeah.
They've got a system that supposedly you
don't know what really was under
classification.
What does it stand for?
High frequency active auroral research
programs.
So the idea behind this was they wanted
to do research on the Aurora and didn't
they want to see if they could
communicate using it and sending radio
waves?
Horizon Radar,
right?
Yeah.
That and they also wanted to be able to
send radio signals to places where they
wouldn't really know.
What does that have to do with
stratospheric aerosol and just really go
into the atmosphere.
Well,
the speculation this.
I've interviewed the private head of it.
Okay.
I'm to let him on my work with the
hottest harp work with the chem trails.
What do they let me check goes on?
Only A.
my chronic amount of small amount of
what harp does is in the atmosphere.
It's bouncing off the Aurora borealis
and then resonating back through in a,
in a deep earth,
a communication program to satellites
and other things through the planet,
so it's something she can communicate
with satellites through the satellites,
down to the submarines.
So here it goes.
This is an actual business definition.
How harp works.
The facilities transmitters send radio
waves according to hold on.
Let's just read it.
First waves upwards into the ionosphere
between 100 and 350 kilometers altitude.
The resulting heating effect creates
irregularities and the electron density
there,
which in turn allows communication
signals as from satellites to be relayed
off the ionosphere.
That's not what it really does.
Then they can shoot the shadow light
frequency coded through the Earth to
submarines.
Now,
what is this website from there?
The Jamie bully.
You want the real stuff?
I'll tell you.
Yeah,
sure.
Okay.
Let me explain something.
Dot Com.
I had the head of the heart program on
just fucking.
I got contacted about 10 years ago and
they said the head of the Hart project
really lecture work.
He liked to come on interviews online.
He liked to come on and tell everybody,
and about 30 minutes in a colonel came
on the line and said,
sorry,
during a break and cut the guy off.
Well,
I mean this really happened.
Q spooky music cue,
spooky music,
but I believe you.
That's a true story.
I want to know.
I want to know that I want another
relationship between like what are the
chem trails have to do?
Do you think trump is going to look into
the SIA project at the CIA has green
lit.
He is starting out with vaccines.
As I told people he would do
investigating and all the damage they've
caused.
The ultimate.
That's good to start the vaccines.
Get that shit together too,
for sure,
but what about the SAI programs that the
CIA has greenlit?
You think he's going to get into that
next level?
Said,
we want him to communicate with these
microphones.
Internet shouldn't be like,
you're so locked onto this.
Here's the problem with all this asset
shit.
Most of what you see when you see those
jets flying around those clouds behind
them,
most of that is just a fringe in exactly
the infusers that with a real program.
What's the real progress?
Well,
here's the thing.
You're right,
and so his job,
because the world is complex,
there are secret and clauses,
secret and public programs to test
manipulation of the weather and weather
systems.
The Arabs are doing it,
the Chinese are doing it.
The Russians are doing people being
cloud seeding for a hundred years now
whether manipulation,
but they're doing it for different
purposes in that not to produce.
Right.
I had been living keep going.
The head of the US weather weapon
program for 27 years on my show first
because I saw it was he.
I saw that he was in the panhandle of
Texas.
I called him running a major cloud
seeding company with his son and got the
90 year old to Austin and then after
that he totally freaked out because the
cio came to his house.
Do you want the interviews on Youtube?
Do you want to know what he said?
Yes,
he was a world war two fighter pilot and
I said at the end of World War Two,
he flew the first planes and hurricanes
in the Atlantic.
That's pretty gangster and into typhoons
that are even faster in the Pacific and
then he and then he also let squadrons
in Vietnam flooding everything up to 10
feet of water out of clear blue skies
with an hour's work with,
with their,
with their chemicals pass.
You have to be to do that.
It's super bad ass.
Fly into a hurricane or a typhoon Jesus.
He's the first guy to do it.
Holy Shit.
Anyways,
he's super bad ass.
I don't know.
He's alive.
He's been living at 90.
He was still all there and I thought not
to kicked my ass is big texts and I felt
like I was.
The guy was with me anyways,
so.
So we're sitting there and he gives me
all this data and I can't believe and he
showed me all these classified photos
and stuff because they just,
he classified the file.
No one thought to call the old man from
Lubbock or whatever it was.
Right?
So I call him,
I get him on,
they sent a bunch of people that their
company and threatened them the next
week after I heard it and he laid it
out.
He said in 1967 when we certified at the
Stanford Research Institute,
he was able to control hurricanes,
create hurricanes and steer hurricanes.
All that got black budgeted shut down.
And then they got into these arrays
where they could use antennas and out of
that,
and Westinghouse came,
came the,
uh,
the,
the whole heart program show in the
sixties.
They could create control and steer or
kill hurricanes.
That's why you google now.
Bill and Melinda Gates bought all those
patents and the quote,
Bill Gates is going to save the world
from bad weather.
Bill Gates wants to stop hurricanes
googling.
So I.
So let me build the weather machine.
Let me pause for a second.
How does the,
how do,
how do they manipulate a hurricane?
So the hurricane's going to happen,
how do they break it up?
Okay.
If it's was coming into lands there,
problem with with Ariel arrays,
projecting into the sky,
they can break it up or strengthen it or
kill it or steer it because it's all
negative.
I miss doing that with harp will.
They've got.
They've got heart bases all over the
place.
They call them doppler radar facilities.
Oh,
the government.
Once your local city,
they have doppler radar.
I thought that was so you could have a
guy in front of the window.
The script,
that's it.
Like one 10th of one percent.
They can crank those arrays up that have
a massive.
Your lights might go when they do it a
little bit.
Yeah,
because they'll use the whole power of
your town through the doppler radars and
then they control it.
The US has a giant weather weapon hidden
in front of everybody and every time
it's city and poor Russians and Chinese
are just discovering.
All the US has weather weapons that can
knock them all out.
Right now,
Bill Gate's control,
the weather ideas for barges to pump
water from the depth
of the ocean to create some sort of a
roadblock for the hurricane.
Since her gains pull power from the
water's warm,
temperature is cooling,
the water could have theoretically,
theoretically dismantle the hurricane.
Well,
it sounds like a good idea though.
None of the deployment is loving is it?
Doesn't that sound like a genius idea?
You spray cold water until the trails.
O'Brien Brennan in the front of the CFR
is saying,
we were doing this because for global
warming and we got to save them about
about geoengineering.
Chem trails.
You were wrong about the dinosaurs.
Not being rude,
but hey,
what about that?
They're.
They're coming out saying,
hey,
there's gonna.
Be some countries that don't.
That aren't going to be for it.
We got to figure out how we're going to
deal with them because you want me to
have the audience.
The big cigarette.
Yes.
Was the big relation.
Keep going with that.
Come on,
man.
Don't change the subject.
Keep going with that.
You're not done with Livingston.
Imagine you're here,
but imagine that me and Joe were
actually.
You got me off on.
You want me here about Ronald Reagan to
later finish the s a.
He doesn't know about this,
but it's a minor deal.
What do you know about the SSI program?
Look,
let's get this done.
When most of the real programs are just
like fronts for something else,
it's not even real.
So you don't think they're spraying shit
into the atmosphere?
No.
There is a program for Geo Engineering.
There's a program in place and you just
said it's the doppler radar system and
harp and what else and an aerial
spraying still the most effective and
what do they do?
They do have pat.
When you say an aerial spraying,
what are they spraying?
Barium salts.
Alumina oxide.
Radioactive isotopes in the air balloon
was because because it does a bunch of
things,
they're testing a bunch of stuff.
They're they're.
They're manipulating things.
Listen,
our pedagogy,
why do you have evidence that they're
doing this and spraying aluminum and
Barium,
whatever it is in line and the
Department of Energy.
It's all public.
Just like he just go online and watch
the Chinese dude get jacked by a tiger.
That's great.
That's how to go to the Department of
Energy Dot Gov and you can watch cfr.
CIA director at the time,
Brendan it admitting all this.
This is all public.
Yeah.
He talked about,
but he'd know.
I saw it.
I saw the video.
We could play the video and go over it
if you want,
but he's talking about various options
for controlling global warming.
They're laying out the future.
Look,
if global warming is a guy.
Hold on,
hold on a second.
If global warming is real,
we know it is right.
Don't you think they would have?
You don't believe global warming is
real.
Keep measuring these temperatures and
scientists keep saying,
okay,
well let's find out.
Let's find out what the real.
Okay.
I believed that it was high.
It goes cold.
There's always micro temperature change
this shift.
She was the only thing that ever
happened that's taxes to Al Gore won't
fix it.
Okay.
I think we all agree that the shifts,
but what I'm saying is there absolutely
is global warming,
right?
What is the CEO?
The second talking house.
When my dad
was a kid,
the 19 fifties for three or four months
out of the year,
it was below zero or freezing and you
had to chop wood and he'd freeze your
ass off and all houses had,
even in the south had,
had,
you know,
had all sorts of chimneys and um,
for fireplaces because it was freezing
cold and now there has been a warming
period,
but that's part of a normal global cycle
based on the sun.
All these astrophysicist or.
Sure.
The whole thing about claiming it's the
carbon we put out the earth is carbon
star.
There's a carbon cycle.
That's the big story I want to get to
the globalist.
Want to tax if they can tax oxygen,
carbon dioxide,
water or sunlight,
they have total control over the whole
life cycle of the planet.
Well,
let's play the video.
Let's play the video.
This,
this CIA guy talking about it because
what I inferred from and trying to come
up with some sort of solutions,
if global warming becomes a giant,
White Brennan is a fricking known.
What hobbyist would show Joe?
What is the CIA that's watch the video
for global warming?
It's a good question.
What do they have to do?
I don't know what the CIA does.
Due Diligence.
They were never built that stop the
spread of communism,
but it's an intelligence agency.
They're part of the environment.
Okay.
They were a part of the intelligence
community and if they got hired,
I would imagine.
This is just me guessing right off the
top of my head.
If they got hired to assess a threat and
a threat being from global warming,
like what?
What do we have to worry about?
Are we really going to lose cities?
Do we really have an issue?
Goes Down,
give George Soros and the UN total power
for a 100 trillion per decade.
Global tax to micromanaging,
surveil everything humans do.
Let's say is if carbons toxic,
they've got to surveil it.
Thus they have a jurisdiction to control
our lives.
Okay.
Hold on.
Why does it say debunked?
CIA director admits chem trails,
geoengineering,
stratospheric aerosol injections.
Uh,
so it says the claim guys,
hold on,
hold on.
At the counsel admits geoengineering in
the form of stratospheric aerosol
injections.
Sai is taking a place I eat.
Kempter is taking place it chem trails,
and the rebuttal is nowhere in his
speech.
Is there an admission that an sai
program has already taken place?
The part where Brendan mentioned
geoengineering is just one example.
Out of several not often mentioned
issues with the CIA monitors for
potential elements of instability in the
world.
A ski program,
if ever implemented,
could penetrate conflicts and security
threats if misused.
The CIA's jobs to consider all types of
concepts,
concepts for potential future problems
and threats,
including the science oriented concepts.
That's totally.
Let me break down the right,
but isn't that possible?
And we're done.
But what that guy just said,
is that possible?
No.
That's basically what Brendan said,
but what he's saying is that there are
potential threats.
He only.
Mentally,
it's an issue,
right?
So he's not admitting that he had.
There's an Sar,
but let me.
Let me tell you.
Okay,
go ahead.
Tell me everybody debates how many
programs there are,
all the specifics.
A lot of that's classical.
Fuck.
You can google Shyna launches,
major weather control operations 10
years ago,
right?
Or
Qatar does it,
or Saudi Arabia or UK or for sure people
have studied.
No,
no,
there's.
They call it study.
There was a giant hell in 2005.
The Department of Energy Program for
Aerosol testing was $5 million a year.
So under US Code Title Fifty Chapter
Thirty Two subsection 1,528,
paragraph B.
is that true?
You nailed that,
right?
Yes,
yes.
From under US code.
Do you live on that obelisk?
That was fucking insane.
Let me just tell you.
I get into.
Remember the time last time with Cheetah
fought under us.
Code title,
Finish Number Thirty 2,528,
paragraph B.
that's.
That's insane.
Under that,
say it's slow that Jamie.
Write it up.
Jaylin was code title 50 chapter.
I say it fast.
Remember us code title 50 chapters,
Statute Section 1,528,
paragraph eight,
subsection 128.
The real fast brand fact speed.
Kenya speech came and say it.
It's like one thought.
Jesus us code section one.
There's restrictions on use of human
subjects for testing of chem trails.
Go,
go back,
back.
There you go.
Or biological agents,
right now,
what they do in this is they say it's
illegal to test unless it's for
research.
Then you're allowed to kill people.
It was for research purpose.
You know,
that's how some of those Japanese whaler
vessels get away with killing whales.
Still.
They say it's for research purposes and
they kill the whales and seldom dark
shit.
The elites,
the elites are the mad scientist
engineers.
I'm gonna.
Give you the big secret man if you want
to do.
I'm not kidding around.
I know I'm not eating.
The thing is they call their the high
priests.
They're scientists,
they're engineers.
They're allowed to kill people.
Test stuff on kids and jet black people
with syphilis,
all the declassified stuff because they
are scientists.
All the real executioners tortures or
most of them were people making
decisions are doctors and so it's all
medical doctor stuff in this big
breakaway civilization of scientist.
Okay?
And so that's what they've built and
under,
under under researched provisions,
they could even kill anybody.
They want.
All right,
I'm going to go back because we took
Eddie turn on chem trails,
but we did it to side track from what
you were saying about the moon and I
want to go back to what you're saying
because you were saying that there was
two completely different missions and
one of them was real and that there was
some sort of contact with aliens.
No,
I was getting to that or I'm saying I
had a top.
Is that what you were implying?
Taught?
Well,
well,
let's just say this.
It's mind blowing.
I was told by a top NASA individual,
Raymond Tig that indeed there was a
breakaway program and that he heard and
saw transmissions on some back channels
of real feeds and advanced ships that
he'd never even seen that basically
didn't even look like they were anything
that he could imagine that was
classified and he knew about some
classified programs for every program
you saw,
there was at least 10 programs that were
sacred.
That's a bit about NASA.
Ninety percent sacred or more,
and so he knew about a cloud,
a bunch classified programs,
and he was shaking
transmissions and things coming back and
talk to people about a whole breakaway
program they sent.
That was a lot safer,
a lot bigger than the moon.
Then they had guys up in orbit just
basically so that even other foreign
governments from the trajectory point,
we think they were getting transmissions
back from the moon.
So they had people out basically out
outside of the regular orbit.
We just go around in circles or is it
geosynchronous where you're in one spot
transmitting back from mathematical spot
to look like transmissions to full
directions and everybody,
all the real mission was going on,
uh,
on the moon.
So you believe they went to the moon,
do you think that it was buzz Aldrin and
Neil Armstrong,
clickonomy everything.
He died.
He said,
I'm going to meet with you tomorrow.
And he done too.
That's like a movie.
He told me I'm ready.
I'm going to tell you everything.
And then he was just totally,
it was crazy.
But he did admit to you that,
uh,
what the public got was fake.
Yeah.
He,
he couldn't get into it.
Well,
there's some footage from the moon that
looks so ridiculous and most people have
never seen some footage of them that.
Here's,
here's the big speculation.
This is one of the really big ones was
that there was a lot of footage that
they did where they were doing tests
that they wound up just using for press
releases.
They using like to say this is actual
footage on the right stuff for the
project because they wanted to be
guaranteed of it,
the real truth.
But there was a thing with Michael
Collins,
Gemini Fifteen,
there was a test photo of him with like
a test rig on and it was like suspended
and you can see the background behind
him.
It was clear that he was suspended on
wires and they took that same photo in,
blacked it out and used it as a press
photo of him on an actual space walk.
But it's the same exact photo stuff.
Yeah.
They do that where they just go over it
with it back then.
And you see you actually use an exact
domain.
Here's the thing,
my dad,
when he was just like a junior in high
school,
was in the plan to program at ut and
they already had cd roms and computers
and they had a nuclear,
a plant under,
but nobody knew about it.
My Dad going about this when I was a
teenager and I would like later go to
the library,
couldn't find it,
and then I googled it.
It's not even really in the news,
but I've gone to ut and talked to them
and I go,
yeah,
you know about the reactor,
the building reactor that Austin's got.
And then no one even knew that Austin
has two nuclear reactors in North
Austin.
What?
Yeah.
But the poem was my.
That was for you.
That was after he was in college.
They built a reactor under which
building in Austin,
Texas.
It's big.
It's a big railway system under there,
but it's,
it's built right under,
right under,
like I said,
gesture.
So there's a nuclear reactor in Austin,
Texas.
How many people know about this?
You know,
it's in the literature and my dad told
me about it when I was a kid.
I thought,
I mean,
I believe my dad,
my dad told me about Dallas hospital
that was killing people for their organs
for like six years later.
I saw it on 60 minutes.
Why?
They were killing people for organs.
Really.
My Dad told me about that in Dallas,
Texas on 60 minutes.
Yeah.
My Dad said when I was 16 years
ago or 15 taken driver's course,
she said,
don't sign that organ donor card.
I know hospitals that kill you.
Jesus.
And I said,
dad,
you're kidding.
He goes,
no.
He was an oral surgeon and rewired jaws
because I've heard this one killed
people all the time.
Is one of the creepiest things you ever.
Can you imagine doctors that get
kickbacks for Oregon's.
They kind of let the see stars are seen
as the highest caste,
but the elite,
so they're the ones pulling all the
stuff.
I'm telling you,
man,
you know how creepy it would be like to
find out that a nurse that you were
working with was killing people,
but that's a story that happens over and
over until the crazy smart killer.
There's been a bunch they get.
They get.
No,
no,
no.
These nurses that say nurses decide they
don't want to take care of somebody and
they poisoned them.
They.
They have someone that maybe someone's
dying slow and they don't like it and
they just get tired of dealing with
their bullshit some of the time.
The district.
Oh yeah.
A lot of the times,
their sadistic.
There's been a lot worse than I have
about facts.
You're absolutely on target.
You don't.
It's no worse than everything.
Everything I know and you're on target.
You just pretend you're not.
No one just knew that document off the
top of your head like that.
So rain man.
I must have been obsessed with chem
trails,
right?
No.
I know a bunch of other.
He's got a crazy mind.
Had a photographic memory.
Tell us about 35 and now it's not good
anymore.
Steals that from me,
stuff I remember,
but I,
I want to tell you guys the big
enchilada.
Please.
The Big Enchilada.
Wear these headphones.
No.
Well,
the problem is when we don't have
headphones on,
we talk over each other.
It's hard when three people are talking,
you know,
it's just,
it's none of our fault.
It's just natural.
The conspiracy.
You,
you're,
you are Bill Hicks,
Huh?
No,
I'm younger than him.
Totally different.
I love how I haven't had any success.
It's all Bill Hicks.
He was a funny guy,
but give me a fricking break,
man.
Listen to those families call me before
and said,
please stop the people saying your Bill
Hicks and all these damn people.
Don't worry about that.
Put the headphones back on.
Sorry.
We have to be fine.
So I need to know.
I need to know what do you know about
aliens and how much are aliens?
Real.
Alright,
let.
This is really big.
So.
Okay.
Put another shot of that media at the
south property.
The question is,
what does Donald Trump know about?
Oh yeah,
it was.
He know now,
right?
Because he's in the office.
That would be the first thing.
I think that Joe Rogen experience
deserves it.
That's the first thing I did.
I would run to the office and I'd go,
who's got the documents?
Who's got the alien documents?
Who's got them?
That would be the first thing I would
want to know.
Right.
Cheers sir.
Boring Shit.
I got to piss too.
You're a robot.
You never have to piss 'em.
Alright.
Let me give you my best please.
Deep research approximation once.
What do you think is going?
But it.
Am I wrong to his.
Still hold out.
Hope that aliens are real because I tell
you has one.
The two guilty pleasures that I still
cling to his big foot and aliens.
Those are two big foot.
Not so much.
I wish it was real,
but I just don't.
Yes.
Big Wood Trim.
No.
Come on Daddy.
Are you ready?
Yes.
I'm gonna.
Give you the big enchilada.
Joe.
There are aliens in this room right now
for real?
Yeah.
You're not of this world,
Bro.
Me,
you're the alien.
Oh Wow.
I didn't know.
It's like,
um,
there was like an old comic book about
that,
about some dude who was a forgetful
professor and then he realized at the
end of it he was actually an alien from
another planet that's sent down here to
monitor people.
He just forgot,
well,
here's what the elite belief,
and let me be very clear as to what.
He'll tell you some context.
I only go with what I can prove.
Oh,
thank you.
And people can't even handle that.
Okay.
Well,
I'm really surprised how much you knew
every angle of so called pizza gate that
I even forgot.
Well,
it's to meet.
obviously we both have children and when
you hear about someone that wants to
molest children,
it's a special kind of evil to special
and it's.
And it's also a special kind of bizarre,
twisted sickness that the human mind is
capable of latching onto the programming
to want to take care of kids and be nice
to them.
There's something very crazy about
people's brains and there's something
very crazy about the weird variables
that can potentially happen.
I agree with all sorts of weird,
crazy aberrations in standard behavior.
You know like this,
the standard behavior of bunch of people
that are just normal folks.
You got kids.
I got kids.
Oh,
get the kids together for a play date.
You sit down and you have a couple of
beers.
You laugh.
You Joe,
have a good night.
Bob Guyton.
Steve.
That's fucking normal shit right?
When you're normal and there's normal
people around you,
you assume that everybody is basically a
good person.
We all have our problems.
Normal that your wife comes into the
bedroom.
She,
you get going.
You don't look at a five year old and
think that's what I want.
No,
there's some were trying to say is
there's some people out there that have
this horrific programming.
Whatever the fuck it is that causes it
as a bunch of psychologists trying to
speculate and figure out what causes to
be beat in the head with a ball pin
hammer.
The thing is it's real and it's.
It's terrifying.
Candida.
It's going on.
We can't deny it's real and it's also
like fucking jared from subway,
the subway guy,
the subway guys in jail for being a
pedophile and they fuck they came up and
they usually have high intelligence and
there's armies were fighting a pedophile
conspiracy,
but beyond that it's a vampire
conspiracy and that they are
interdimensionally sucking the essence
of our youth and they believe they're
possessed by an off world entity.
They do.
Yeah.
And Joe,
I've been on air 22 years.
I don't get into aliens,
metaphysical religion,
any of that.
I've studied the elite and I've also
communicated with a lot of the top
people and,
and,
and if you want to know,
I will actually break down right now the
best knowledge right now.
What's happening on the planet,
what's happening?
Let me give you a basic.
Just sculpt.
Okay?
I love when you can use that word with
full confidence.
I've never said that.
Let me give you a basic gestalt.
I'd be like,
oh my God,
it's such a fraud.
No,
you're not,
you know,
but that's what I would think if I use
that word now you'll get all this shit
you already have.
Most of the static is you're a bookworm
or research warm and a good way.
The elite are all about transcendence
and living forever and the secrets of
the universe and they want to know all
this.
Some are good,
some are bad,
some are a mix,
but the good ones don't ever want to
organize the battles and want to
organize because they lost after power.
Powerful consciousness don't want to
dominate other people.
They want to empower them so they don't
tend to get together until things are
really late in the game.
Then they come together.
Evils always defeated because good is so
much stronger and we're on this planet
and Einstein's physics shut at.
Max Planck says,
shut her off.
There's at least 12 dimensions and now
that's all the top scientists and
billionaires are coming out saying it's
a false hologram.
It is artificial.
The computers are scanning and and
finding tension points where it's
artificially projected and gravity's
bleeding in to this universe.
That's what they call it.
Dark matter,
so we're like a thought or a dream
that's a whisk in some computer program,
some God's mind,
whatever they're approving it all.
It's all coming out now.
There's like this sub transmission zone
below the third dimension that's just
turned over.
The most horrible things is what it
resonates to and it's trying to get up
into the third dimension.
That's just a basic level consciousness
to launch into the next levels and our
species is already way up at the fifth,
sixth dimension,
consciously our best people,
but there's this big war trying to like
basically destroy humanity because
humanity has free will and there's a
decision to which level we want to go
to.
We have freewill,
so evil is allowed to come and content
not just good and the athletes
themselves believe they're racing.
We using human technology to try to take
our best minds and build some type of
breakaway civilization where they're
going to merge with machines,
transcend and breakaway from the failed
species.
That is man,
which is kind of like a false
transmission because they're thinking
what they are is ugly and bad.
Projecting it onto themselves instead of
believing notes,
a human test about building us up,
and so google was set up 18,
19 years ago.
This was.
I knew about this before it was
declassified.
I'm just saying I've good sources that
they wanted to build a giant artificial
system and Google believes that the
first artificial intelligence will be a
super computer based on the neuron
activities of the hive mind of humanity
with billions of people wired into it
with the Internet of things and so all
of our thoughts go into it and we're
actually building a computer that has
real neurons in real time that's also
psychically connected to us that are
organic creatures so that they will have
current prediction powers,
future prediction powers a true crystal
ball.
But the big secret is once you have a
crystal ball and know the future,
you can add stimuli beforehand and make
decisions that control the future.
And so then it's the end of
consciousness and free will for
individuals as we know.
And a true two point,
oh,
in a very bad way.
Hive mind consciousness with an ai
jacked into everyone knowing our hopes
and dreams,
delivering it to us,
not in some pkd wire head system where
we plug in and give up on consciousness
because of unlimited pleasure,
but because we were already wired in and
absorbed before we knew it,
by giving over our consciousness to the
system,
our daily decisions that it was able to
manipulate and control into a larger
system.
There's now a human counterstrike taking
place to shut this off before it gets
fully into place and to block these
systems and to try to have an actual
debate about where humanity goes and cut
off the pedophiles and psychic vampires
that are control of this ai system
before humanity is destroyed.
Wait a minute,
is only controlled of Ai.
How'd they get had the pedophiles
getting control of the pet,
the pedophiles at,
uh,
at whatever level rule the devil,
whatever you want to call it.
This interdimensional thing that gives
them advanced offworld technology.
The fallen one that's not of this world
is giving them advanced systems have
been used before on other populations.
What that Satan.
But what are you talking about?
Let's say explain that you just see
something,
something that you know the stupid
preacher tells you about who's totally
controlled or something you read about
in the news or TV,
right?
This is an interdimensional force that
wants to influence us to build something
that absorbs us and kills us rather than
the divine.
A freewill we're given to build
something much better than empowers the
species.
So the species is now making a decision
on its entire future.
When you're getting this from,
from that,
that's what it is.
But where are you getting it?
I know from,
from looking at all the data,
researching and studying it,
watching the enemy,
that's the big decision that humanity
has now got before us.
So if you were directing someone to
investigate this on their own,
how would they do that?
So if you say,
here's the problem,
you get someplace.
Finally in deep research where it's what
every culture already said,
what everybody already knew,
what they're telling you.
A movies like promethium,
what the elite admit the New York Times
they believe in is this,
you know,
a seated by offworld systems.
Panspermia,
yes.
Everything,
everything.
They're doing points towards this and
then you read their own writings.
They believe we're this ugly,
fallen,
ugly species.
We're all going to be killed there.
The rich billionaires who are better
than us and they're going to merge with
machines and become gods and go to the
next level.
Don't you think that most people who
extrapolate from where we stand today
with our cell phones and our apple
watches and our integration with the
computer and the Internet constantly,
don't you think that most people see
that there's going to be some sort of
symbiotic connection?
It's a very easy thing.
They were saying it before.
I understand,
but a lot of people were saying,
but here's a problem.
Who engineered what we were given?
What is the point of the back door at
the Trojan horses?
Hey,
here's what I'm Jenny who engineered
what?
Here's what.
Here's what I'm telling you.
The elite,
the elite literally believe
interdimensionally.
They were given this information and
then built it and here's the thing.
They built it and Google admits he would
have data dumps to wire two years ago
that they're building an ai that will in
human consciousness freewill and take
over and the next species will rise out
of that.
They've already decided.
Our species people have been taught.
Marshall Mcluhan was talking about that
50 fucking ago.
Here's the old.
They
built it Amazon two years ago at mets.
They can already with 99 percent
certainty pick what their regular users
are going to order.
Alex,
before they hold on a second,
ready instead of dragging this out to
some nefarious end,
isn't it entirely possible that all
these futurists,
all these technological innovators,
they all see the same end game if
there's going to be some sort of a
complete integration between people,
but it's the artificial intelligence
that historically everybody saw this
coming,
right,
and so this big,
all the futurists,
all the people that started in the
future before a silicon chips were
created.
The point Marshall Mcluhan,
I think it was in the 1970 said that
human beings are the sex organs of the
machine world,
and he was saying even back then that
human beings are eventually going to
integrate or become something that's a
part of telling you is there's a
centralized system of what they're
building that isn't naturally occurs.
Who is that?
Where artificial he was doing the elitch
believe they're getting off world
building.
These things that you're just describing
right now.
I mean if you actually read with all the
global is say you've obviously read
their writings,
you know this show,
they are getting knocked off world,
but interdimensional communications to
build this system that we see lowers our
ICU,
makes us live less.
I've never asked is okay,
but when you're making these big
statements,
they've getting into dimensional signals
is telling them to create these systems
that lower iqs.
That's something you got to really
prove.
Like if there's.
Okay,
please.
If there's something you can show all
the studies show screen time,
all the computers,
lowering our as lowing fertility must be
right there.
Was that a case?
Is that a case of a somebody's holding a
gun to your head?
Let me tell you about me.
I'm addicted to this God damn thing.
I love watching videos.
I love.
I love taking pictures and shit.
I love looking at humanity.
There's a lot of beautiful things he
does,
but I'll tell you,
they're very addictive.
Very addictive.
So.
But hold on a second.
Let me stop you right there.
I don't necessarily think that's
engineered to be addictive.
I think it's engineered to be really
well and the fact work really well and
the fact that it works really well is
very addictive.
Just like little kids look at a screen,
you put a fucking television in front of
them when they're one year old and play
some stupid commercial and they're like,
whoa,
Joe.
They picked a second.
No,
they don't.
They made a better.
Hold on a second.
They made better and better technology
that we're not designed to absorb.
Human beings have exactly set through.
At the moment we have the exact same DNA
that we did 10,000
years of the Atlantic when there was
nothing like television.
There was nothing like movies,
there was nothing like stereo headphones
and project,
but don't go on.
You're crazy when you're interrupted.
My crazy rant.
I am telling you that this is a natural
progression of this massive infatuation
that we have with technology.
They don't have to engineer it.
It's natural.
It happens to you.
It happens to me.
Happens to anybody who's looking at
cooler and cooler.
Special effects in movies.
All that stuff is a natural.
Steve Jobs wouldn't let his kids play
with an ipad.
Well then he's a cunt.
He's a cunt.
Let your kids play with.
Fuck's wrong.
That right ran.
I'm not disagreeing with you.
Interrupted it 10 times.
You fuck.
Oh,
I'm to let a motherfucker rant.
Rant,
rant,
rant.
Then I'm done.
Now.
Shit,
they're going to get back to this.
We're not talking about the weather.
It can tell you that right now.
Let me tell you right now.
Fuck.
Cloud.
Let me tell you.
I'm trying to break this down.
The whole thing is being set up to
control.
Okay?
What I'm telling you when you're talking
about the elites and interdimensional
signals that they're receiving,
they're telling us to lower Iq.
You can't just say that.
Need proof.
Okay.
Let me give you a proof.
That sounds so crazy by the way,
Miriam.
Yeah.
Oh,
that sounds so crazy.
I wonder where the aliens was.
They honor.
You know what?
It's really cool to say the computer
simulation,
but it talks about that.
Everyone says no,
but they're saying that will be easily,
easily pitch.
Oh yeah,
we're in a computer simulation,
but then when you talk about
interdimensional like magical shit,
like,
wait a minute.
Exactly.
Magic is a technology that hasn't been
discovered yet.
Exactly,
and that's what these videos are fucking
magic for you and we.
You and I could do this right now and we
could go like here.
We'll do it right now.
This is what's what we're going to do.
We're going to go right now.
You want to talk some magic because this
really is fucking magic.
We're going to do instagram live right
now.
We're not instagram live.
We're doing like one of those little
instagram stories is a whole new,
a whole new thing.
Young Jamie,
am I right?
Fuck.
This isn't live yet.
Oh,
occasionally I did,
but I.
You go a little longer than you.
Let me go on.
What's that?
We're going to go to Alex.
got to piss again.
Go past all these lightweights.
I'm just drinking coffee.
I drank one of these kill cliff coffees.
I drank one order of a butter coffee.
I'm drinking this Erewhon conspiracy.
It's a conspiracy.
I'm drinking some juice.
I had two glasses of whiskey.
That's bullshit.
And these bitches are.
They keep pen.
I don't understand it.
Hold your little girl something.
I take a credit to break that.
That was was his rant.
I'm not sure.
We're going to go back to that.
He's definitely high as fuck,
dude.
This stuff about children's telling him
some fucking.
Exactly.
Crazy shit.
I'm like,
oh my God.
I'm too fucked up.
You fucked up.
I told you we were going to get.
Yeah,
I knew that was the key.
The key to make this podcast super
special was.
Well He.
He asked for the whiskey himself,
so he started the park.
Yours or his?
That's his.
Oh,
that's ours.
No,
That's a gentlemen.
Gentlemen,
live listeners,
this gentleman to record big time.
Record record.
Holy Shit.
Gentleman.
Jack is a.
This is what they sent us.
This right?
It's good.
I mean good and it all tastes terrible.
It's like,
you know,
you're sucking on the devil's asshole.
I mean,
that's kind of half the fun of Whiskey
is that it's disgusting.
It to taste good on instagram.
I love this.
A lot of people thought that this was a,
a,
a conspiracy because Eddie went live on
instagram live and you disappeared.
So there was a lot of talk online ever
existed to bill Hicks.
The globalist are anti human.
They think we're a bunch of dumb
animals,
but where are the aliens?
They're carrying on a shot.
They believe it's not aliens.
Does that have to do with the Luciferian
freemasonry type shit?
I'd love to.
Bones,
skull and bunk.
Breakdown free because I know in the
Albert Pike wrote the Freemason Bible.
He's talking about Luciferian Shit.
So if you're free,
mason proceeding in my hand says he
talks about he founded the KKK.
Go for it.
Tell me about Albert Albert Pike.
No,
I want to give.
I mean,
Joe,
here's the thing.
you,
you brought in,
right to your point about I willing to
miss it.
It'll lead to your point because the
point you brought up,
the whole issue,
this first place,
you brought up the whole point about no
more weed.
Alex,
taking quotes from Buzz Aldrin tells you
you went to,
went to smoke.
He take.
What's the difference?
I'm not trying to dominate to this guy.
He was a nice.
Seriously.
I want to be nice.
Great Guy.
Look,
I love you man.
I'm happy to see you.
But I'm telling you this is that the
globalist admit a lot of this.
It's in a lot of their white papers.
All of the reports come in to actually
give it to you.
I will.
They.
They say they believe they're going to
become gods.
The rest of us are profane and shit
about interdimensional beings.
Given them all the data.
Let me tell you,
you know where the theory of of the
species,
and we're all the Darwin stuff came from
where he had an elucidation and believes
he was given all this stuff from like
demons and I'm not saying that's really
confusing.
Darwin Descartes.
No,
no,
that's.
Donald didn't take hard.
Have it,
isn't he the one that came up with the
idea of science science from a dream.
So Darwin's idea came from Darwin was
like really into watch handling and
stuff.
Yes.
And the guy said he acts like he does
it.
Okay.
Whatever was the guy that.
Yeah,
a lot of those guys,
they get the technology,
they believe from a fricken other
dementia,
you know,
people know all about this as much as I
do or more joe.
And you sit there and act like you don't
know.
I forgot you're afraid to give your
audience all the information,
but you're saying you're saying Joe
Barnes,
but I bring it up making it up to the
center dimensional.
But I just wanted to know where it's
coming.
Definitely the smartest guy showed it,
showed it Darwin,
you know,
pulling it up.
You probably already know that.
I know that Darwin's partner,
the God
that he developed a theory of evolution
where they were,
they both had like a similar theory and
they came together with it and he was
like really into it to the point where
he was into channeling and all sorts of
weird stuff that knows this discredited
him.
I listened to it on radio.
That's what they believe.
I'm not saying it's real.
Shannon's going to have me up here.
I'll clipped it out and that's what I'm
saying.
I'm saying they discredited him and they
just put all the emphasis on Darwin.
That's why you only hear about Darwin's
forward.
Okay.
From Free Mason level,
that's phase two.
Let me tell you,
give up the aliens.
Come on.
I know.
You know things got to go back to you
guys.
What do we do?
You've got to start there,
which is fucking right.
You don't have to do a show like this.
It's great.
I love it.
I'm not mad.
Let me just tell you.
Please do.
If you look at this,
that's what I'm telling you.
I don't believe it.
Okay.
I'm telling you.
She studied with the establishment,
believes none of them are atheist.
They all believe they're getting
interdimensional stuff.
She,
if you go back to Dalton and Wedgewood
and Huxley,
recognize all,
always moderate names.
If you go back to Darwin,
Darwin wrote this,
these letters,
republic.
You can read these online from a
national,
you know royal archives in England and
stuff.
They all believed they were all part of
a secret breeding program with a British
thought.
They would have like this super human if
they bred these six families together to
like create all this,
just like mainland in British history.
This is just known all eugenics history
and then Golten who's related to all
these other guys in the 18 fifties.
He starts having these ideas and he says
there's a double helix which the snakes
for for science and medicine,
and he said we're going to discover the
keys and the building blocks of life,
and he said it's going to be called
biometrics and we'll track everybody by
reading their genetics is what Hitler
freaked out about and picked up and
something like eight of the 14 new
sciences like half or more than half the
sciences that came since the 18 sixties
were all from Dalton and all from
Darwin.
So the media and the liberals give me
this one thing,
the origin of the species,
like I'm not saying it's wrong or right.
It's super heavy.
Like galactic stuff.
They give this to you.
This is only one little boil down.
BSN We'd have.
You go to what these guys really wrote.
They were like inter marrying and
involved in wicked seances and
channeling and,
and,
and all this weird ass crap.
And then they envision,
okay,
there's a double helix DNA discovered
it.
Okay.
Biometrics,
okay.
World government computers,
Atomic weapons give me the equations and
they were like all them,
like going to other scientists meetings
and go,
we believe there is a program where you
take different matter together in
isotopes and it'll cause an explosion
and it's like they were like given
either humans or super advanced already
had this knowledge from somewhere else
in our genetics and were here before and
we're able to then manifest this through
genetic memories and archives or it was
given off world,
but humans like have all this data
compacted and compress ready like
programs that called like the acacia
records or something like that as though
all of it is,
is,
is uh,
Kaushik epic.
Here's the deal.
Epigenetics.
They'll take chickens with eggs and do
10 generations and major universities
that have never seen a hot.
And they put them in these,
like these 20 foot ceilings and they'll
have a triangle.
Fly over in a square,
fall over in a little baby.
Chickens,
neighborcare generation regeneration
generation go on for 15 years.
They fly one hawk over and they all
squat,
yelling,
screaming,
and run into their nest.
Now they never saw hawk and never saw
kill a chicken generation after
generation whiskey.
It was compressed data knowledge of the
Hawk that is passed on genetically.
Yeah.
They say that's why children are always
afraid of monsters that goes down the
Tigers and bears.
I used to be cat.
My son just wants to be chased so much.
He wants to practice getting away from a
predator.
He loves that Demos.
He wants to get away.
You can't catch me and it'll just be
ready to fight predators.
You can't fight.
If you can get the fuck away from that
tiger at the Zoo and China,
I recommend you do that.
Yeah.
My son's good stuff.
Not even.
You probably wouldn't be saying
Alexander one cloth.
You might not even get second.
I'll.
I'll admit that.
I was like,
Oh shit.
We shouldn't have let them smoke weed,
but then now you're thinking.
Brought it back down.
You came back.
You came back here and keep it going.
You're going in a good place right now.
Keep it going.
You're talking about a.
Now you're getting into Albert Pike.
Ooh,
well he's the founder of the KKK.
Kept chomping confederate general head
of the Illuminati worldwide at that
time,
so let's establish something that's like
maybe people that are listening to this
might go,
what in the fuck are these guys ramble
about?
Well,
I'm exposed to establish this throughout
history from the beginning of organized
human secret knowledge folks don't want
to pass on as your own.
There's also been people conspiring to
control whatever.
It's the sign.
What end people conspiring to control
whatever aspect of it,
whether it's political,
whether it's the military,
like whatever it is.
There's always been that.
It's always happened,
has been military coups.
All throughout history.
There's been wars all throughout and had
a peaceful and bro.
How so?
I mean,
dude,
the intelligence community leaked all
the data to break down the globalist.
He Eddie's asking the intelligence
community leaked all what data they
looked all the way he likes.
He's over here saying,
wait a minute.
Are you saying that the Russians didn't
do it?
No.
Really,
how do you know this?
Because the mainstream media says,
hold on,
Joe.
Give me a break to.
No,
no,
no.
I just want to know how,
you know,
if you've ever,
if you've known me for like 16,
17 years.
Yes.
Do you ever known me to say I have a
source that I'm making it up?
Be Honest.
No,
no,
no.
I mean I've got sources so you can't
tell us how,
you know.
Let's just say I got data today from a
head of state and what did he say?
I can't tell you.
Okay.
Don't tell me the point is you didn't
tell me.
Yeah,
but the frame is we screwed it up and
released it early so it caused a
problem.
Explain the whole Russian diversion.
We didn't mean on purpose.
So I'm always mad at us.
Bust out with that one thing because
there's intelligent people like my
students,
like you hear that
you don't believe the Russians.
So where should it come from?
How do they believe that?
Yeah.
Why are you saying that?
The intelligence agency leaked all this
and not Russia because I was told before
it was all leaked by the former director
of psychological operations,
the CIA.
I was going to come out.
He told you that it was going to be
leaked.
Yeah.
Before I was never like embed with the
CIA.
I've interviewed people from the CIA,
NSA,
defense,
intelligence,
you name it.
Over the years.
I mean it's all over the news,
but it's entirely possible.
General Flynn,
former head of defense intelligence,
tweets.
All my articles.
I'm not telling you it's some secret.
I mean the enemy knows.
The point is,
is that I'm seen as an honest good
person and understand what's going on.
I'm out for humanity.
I don't want personal power.
I want to help people,
but it isn't an entirely possible.
I mean like how,
how does the information like that get
out?
Well,
there's an open rebellion against the
criminals have hijacked our government
and so we overthrew the globalist and
Obama and we're taking him over in
France,
in Italy,
in Spain,
in Greece,
in the UK.
The only place we're not successful so
far is Canada.
So you just took Australia about took
Australia with the idea of free.
I'm going to sign it.
What does that mean?
See,
most people sit there and brag about
stuff.
I'm telling you what's really going on,
what does it mean for Australia,
I mean globalist or losing countries
every month right now to the liberty
movement.
What?
What says that these are people that
want you and your family to be
successful and aren't out to hurt you,
to make you poor like the globalist.
There's good people and they used the
intelligence agencies to defeat the
globalist and there's been a major
counter offensive and the globals made
one wrong move.
It happened five years ago.
It was.
It was system wide leak.
Four years ago.
I've had CIA whistleblowers.
All Obama show kernels and special
operations,
you name it,
who were authorized by high level
senators come on my show.
They ran a counter coup.
There was a deal made with radical Islam
to actually take over Europe and then
the United States and by that make us
convert or not convert,
but submit to Islam,
not criticize it or they blow stuff up.
They thought they bring in some new
masculine arm that would make us submit
and it got so bad that even our own
intelligence agencies that had been
corrupted said,
this is too far.
We're not doing it.
And so America,
about four years ago,
sort of coming back up for air and now
we're just overthrowing their whole
system.
There's a huge war going on.
It's beautiful.
We're kicking their ass on every front
now.
Like I said,
at the top,
uh,
it's a,
it's the,
at the dawn of a new age,
you were against George W dot Bush,
Clinton,
Obama,
all that.
You are not a republican or a democrat.
You weren't,
you were against government.
But now it's a new day.
Now the conspiracy theorists like
yourself,
you're the king of them were pro
government and the sheep.
They're like out there protesting,
crying,
explain that.
Well,
I mean,
look,
it's not.
That trumps perfect.
He really genuinely like going into all
these corporate incentives.
At one side of deals,
there's no meetings.
Now there's a lobbyist.
He banned them all for lifetime.
He literally goes in with actuaries and
computer programs and ngos who were
super NSA technology that even had
before he was in and he says [inaudible]
the generals came to him years ago.
They said,
we can deliver all this.
Everybody,
we don't want to make America poor.
We don't want to have big wars.
Who wanted to just have prosperity.
Sarah,
we've got next to free energy.
All these technologies,
cures for cancer.
We're ready to release it.
That's why I talked about the state of
the union or his,
uh,
his first inaugural speech and there was
a will be the second and he just really
cares about humanity and he's not a
satanist.
He doesn't like raping kids.
He likes Super Hot Eastern European
women and just,
you know,
who wants that?
He wants a little Kevin,
you can have that just he's not out to
get humanity.
And he's got the intelligence agencies
totally backing into the hill.
Uh,
and it's just a super epic moment to be
alive.
What's going on so far with trump from
Iran?
Hold on one second.
So what do you think when you,
you said earlier in the podcast,
so you don't think he's perfect,
right?
What do you think he could do different
that would make people accept him?
Well,
I said last week you should just about
torture.
He did the next day just magically
alias.
Because that again,
that you came up with the idea and you
listened to,
what did you say?
The tortures the Zeitgeists and I'm in
the Zeit geist.
So in that Zeitgeists guy,
she just kind of see everything.
Even though you're just a normal person,
you can like look into any avenue of any
your your take on it is that it's good
to have him in despite whatever flaws
people may perceive me as well.
He wants prosperity and he's not a part
of the system that he replaced.
That's why they're totally against.
And he likes full grown women.
Okay.
I believe that you can only have to say
that anymore now,
but I'm just,
I'm just telling you,
most people,
most people acted like to grab the kid
out of your backyard and torture him for
a couple of weeks so they kidnap,
they torture.
They raised kids thought that come
combined.
The emails and the emails are like,
well,
these are kind of exhausted.
We're about to have to retire them,
so you need to get in there.
Some of these are damaged.
Look him up.
He didn't believe me.
No,
I believed you.
Look,
I don't know what three year girls in a
big old guy comes in.
It just breaks their jaundice.
So do you think trump's going after him
least?
What's going on?
Oh yeah.
Well,
he's done.
If he's successful,
it's an entire route.
Like a lot of people aren't just getting
indicted right now.
They're getting a good to take care of
right now about the Vatican and they
gonna are they weddings?
How is that punch?
Stop trump.
He's the devil stopping anything.
We've got stopping.
That's the Vatican said.
Yeah,
the Vatican.
Pedophiles central issue.
Shitting their pants over trump.
The Vatican is so bizarre.
Imagine truncal and after the Vatican a
country.
What's crazy about it is he was,
because I always wanted.
This is what I ate,
Alex.
I always thought,
how weird is it that everybody knows?
South Park is making a goddamn episode
about them
being pedophiles and get nobody's
investigating what's going on here,
so to me,
and then you watch conspiracy of
silence.
That documentary that never got released
about the whole network.
Then you begin to realize,
Oh shit.
The reason my opinion is the reason no
one's getting arrested at the Vatican at
a high rate anyways is because everybody
at the top is involved.
Let me give you the good news.
I'm not here to kiss the ass of the
establishment.
A lot of patriots in the government who
have always criticized.
It ended up being the people that heard
me bitchy and you bitching do something.
They'd done something and they're really
trying to reverse this whole thing right
now and there is a full out war inside
the government of guys that like to eat
steaks and drink beer and have women
versus a bunch of pot bellied.
Pedophiles,
Whoa,
Jesus Christ.
What's really fucked up is that the
people that before the Sandusky thing
came out that people rounded,
probably heard rumors.
That was probably someone who to talk.
Someone that says something,
but nobody really wanted to believe it.
When it did happen.
Well,
in conspiracy of silence is a
documentary you can watch it never got
released.
They're talking about the base,
the headquarters of the pedophile
network.
It's an international network,
is an Omaha,
Nebraska at boy's town.
They like taking orphans,
orphans.
There's different levels.
There's guys that we didn't want any
trouble.
They just want to sleep and then there's
cycles.
They want to go kidnap.
There's like the hard core people and
you know what?
At top officials and in every aspect of
government and celebrity,
it's not everybody,
but it's enough,
so there's enough people involved that
nobody's investigating anybody because
they're all involved.
They all better keep their mouths shut
so crazy that something gets to the
level of the Catholic church.
Got To with it.
Yeah.
No.
I want to hear about a conversation with
myself and Donald Trump.
Yes,
sure.
Go for it.
Allowed to do this.
Wait a minute.
Before you do it,
just let him.
Who cares me drunk and high on
marijuana.
That was this,
this,
this.
Go.
No.
Trump basically said we're going to
clean it up,
Alex.
we know all about it and Alex,
we're going to stop them and we're going
to do it.
But he also said Obama's from Kenya.
Well,
that was when.
That's a huge intelligence op.
You want to write that down.
You will know about Reagan and was
talking about birth certificate.
Now can tell you the full scoop on that.
What do you think happened there?
I know exactly what they told him that
Obama was from Kenya.
They fucked with them.
They don't hear here right now?
Yes.
Okay.
I was going to tell a trump story,
but.
Okay.
I'll do that.
Good.
We'll go back to the trump story sharing
and we're good.
We're good.
Thank you.
Eddie.
Eddie,
Bravo.
Jamie.
You better add extra juice to that time.
Joe.
Hold on.
Apple juice.
Maybe not.
Alex,
come on.
Okay.
One secret is Christ.
If you give me
minutes,
I'm going to fuck another dimension.
How many years?
Seven years.
So we're just about to say what was the.
What was the issue?
Jesus Christ.
Do you remember what the question wants?
Jamie?
What Donald Trump told you now that
wasn't it.
Yeah.
No,
you were about to say what Donald Trump
told you,
but he knows that about.
You want to know about something else?
What the fuck is it about?
But let's leave.
Fuck,
but hold on a second.
We've on fucking with my memory.
What was it?
You were just.
You were just talking about.
I'm not the only one.
I used to have a good memory.
I don't remember.
Oh,
we're too high.
Let's go.
The trump's dot.
I don't do anything with trump.
Trump.
Jamie's going to figure it out.
What is it that one will tell me?
Just a second.
Someone's going to tell him on twitter
and we'll figure this out.
Jesus Christ,
and then I'll write this up.
Problem with being too high and talking
over each other.
He's about to tell you go trump calls
times a week on average 10 hours show.
No,
no,
no.
They should be your longest podcast.
We will definitely peter out before
then.
No,
no,
no.
It go forever.
What is no one knows what the fuck we
were just talking about a minute gap.
We all forget.
Really?
Good question because we're blasted you
better.
You better call your dispensary and get
some answers.
So you were talking about the Vatican.
We were talking about pedophiles in the
Catholic church certificate.
Oh,
that's right.
Okay.
So tell me what.
It's just a place where I'm not ashamed
of this because I got conned.
Went up what I've been calling,
which happens,
you know,
every,
every once in a while I admitted later.
We learned from it.
Okay.
What happened,
dude?
Come on.
I only told you it's funny,
but Kenya,
Kenya,
Kenya.
Okay.
And everything.
I'm going to say your listeners can
write this down.
They can search engine everything I'm
going to say and learned she does for
themselves because the journey with info
wars is.
It's not that I'm that smart.
I'm just like you.
I'm having this journey and I'm going to
show you.
So this is what happened when Obama's
running for office and Hillary's people,
because I follow the news everyday.
Hillary's campaign,
this letter came out,
puts out these born in Kenya and I'm
like,
yeah,
screw her.
I was quietly,
and I'm really ashamed of this,
but I told us there's this.
I'll just say it.
I was,
I was an early on Obama supporter in
that I wanted to try to unify people.
I didn't like John Mccain,
so I said,
yeah,
he's bad.
The Democrats are bad.
But I hated what had happened.
So much food by Obama to.
Well,
I was hopeful.
Let's get let him talk.
I mean,
it wasn't an Obama supporter.
I just didn't attack him.
And you liked it better than the
alternative?
Yeah,
I didn't push him for office.
I was just like,
hoping that all this bs was real show.
And then I started hearing these leaks
and it was from Hillary.
You can google the city.
Hillary first pro generated the whole
the whole deal show.
I'm sitting there hearing debt,
debt.
He's born in Kenya,
I think.
I don't care.
That's a bunch of bs.
And then the articles started coming out
as the right wing picture that who does
the and
it's his wife and my 2006 and seven in
speeches going.
My husband born in Kenya,
knows about the immigrant experience.
It's video.
You can pull up Michelle Obama.
Oh yeah.
Pull it up.
And then.
And then Harvard law review,
which he headed up for at least three
years.
He was the editor and he says,
I was born in Kenya.
A little bitty bar by buys picture.
Oh yeah.
Says he's working,
but he wasn't wearing Kenyan.
Wait,
plug.
Get through this.
Oh.
So that was just like pizza gate is.
I finally learned how to double cross.
Well,
it's,
it's not,
not in pedophilia.
Hold on,
let's hear.
Say here you go.
Let's be testing,
which is still plaguing so many of our
communities,
uh,
which you all know a lot of that is due
to homophobia.
But Barack has led by example when we
took our trip to Africa and visited his
home country in Kenya,
uh,
we'd soak up public HIV test for the
very point of showing folks in Canada.
Okay.
But that doesn't mean that he was
listening to the club,
he just found that fast.
But there's another where she said,
and there's the Harvard law review when
she edited,
where he says,
I was born in Kenya.
Okay,
well that shit up right there.
Or was she saying is his homeland?
Like if you're from Ireland,
like I didn't want to go back to Italy
or Ireland or totally land.
They call it the homeland.
But listen,
let's just going onto what are we
covering?
Kenya trump certificate.
So yeah,
trump got involved in all that.
An old bursar.
We'll go ahead.
No,
no.
So how did,
what did someone leak that information
to him to try to make him look foolish?
Because he chased after it.
Yes.
So we're just researching.
It's anybody from anybody.
Foolish.
So do you think they just maybe made an
incorrect judge that we found out all
about it.
This is stunning information show people
want to say he's illegitimate.
They then look at him in the Harvard law
review saying he's in Kenya,
we look at clubs,
they look at the fact that he won't
release his birth certificate.
He had a name,
name Barry Satara and Indonesia.
He had all these weird cut out names.
All he had like five alias.
Wow.
Why did he wrote that?
He wrote dream look it up because he
wrote dreams of my real father or dreams
of my father.
My real father is the documentary and in
and he talks about Frank Marshall Davis,
the communist famous pornographer that
he spit summers with.
He looked side by sides,
the same guy,
so they were worried that it was gonna
be Frank Marshall Davis,
but it had actually been his mom in like
a scam making money off.
She was CIA bringing back people in the
US and sham marriage is to have them
integrate.
It was basically a cover up.
The fact that his real father was frank,
Marshall Davis,
the Communist,
and so that's who Obama's real dad was
and dreams.
My real father breaks it all down.
It's online and it's pretty powerful
info.
So what does that mean?
It just is a perfect example of you're
not born in Kenya,
you're really born in Hawaii on the main
city based island.
Honolulu to Frank Marshall Davis.
And your grandfather,
CIA,
your mother's CIA.
That's all been declassified here.
This cutout puts mom was a CIA.
Oh yeah.
What was she.
What did she do for the CIA?
She was a sex operator.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and she posed for news photos and kind
of Betty Page style was sex operatives
in photos at Frank Marshall Davis,
his house.
And you know this because you've seen
these.
I've interviewed the people
will involved.
I've read dreams of my father where he
admits I stayed at Frank Marshall Davis,
his house.
He was like my dad.
My grandfather had a special unspoken
relationship with them.
Quotes.
Look up Obama,
frank,
Marshall,
Davis or Obama's father.
What do you think about the conspiracy
theory that the Obama was bred by the
CIA the whole way through all the truths
on a third.
Oh really?
When you say see I,
that just means like
a marketing project.
If whoever was in power at the time for
eight years,
whoever's in charge of that,
whoever shows interest can go in and
then just basically be involved in
controlling the levers of the social
engineering of the society.
So what does that have to do with Obama
growing up?
Did were those rumors that he was in a
CIA agent and Pakistan while he was
supposed to be in Columbia?
Probably.
Exactly.
He probably spent six months.
Yeah.
There's the supposed father Barack
versus the second versus frame marshal
dose.
I think you look more like the other.
Barack.
Okay.
Well look up,
look up,
look up frank.
Marshall Davis is pornography and it's
mine and I will do no such than Obama's
mother.
Clearly in the photos.
And here's his book.
Dreams of my father admitting that he
stayed with Frank Marshall Davis.
Okay.
But,
but listen,
that's not the issue.
So the,
we would,
I asked you though to get back to where
we started from was why did trump chase
after that whole.
He was born in Kenya.
Shit for so long because he knew it was
super hot with the public and he wanted
to know the answer to it as well.
And didn't like the things Obama was
doing.
Hmm.
It was a weird thing,
right?
Because,
uh,
if you were a guy who was a white guy
and we wanted to prove that you're born
in Austria,
but you had some birth certificate that
said you were born in the United States,
he spoke perfect English but yet a
square jaw and you look like you're from
the frozen north.
Like this motherfucker is freeze from
Austria.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
these from fucking Austria.
And then someone like made a big deal
out of it gave you like a fake birth
certificate and people wouldn't do.
You'd never hear racism then.
Interesting.
Like you would hear that.
Yeah,
this guy might have been born in another
country but it wouldn't be president.
So yeah,
it's a race.
I mean,
instantaneously it gets connected to
racism.
There's an assumed racism with almost
any there.
What color?
Barack Obama.
When he accusation you have any Henry
Su's music.
I'm here.
What color he is along the watchtower is
the best ever.
That's pretty God damn good
song.
Yeah.
All of that show.
All I'm telling you is you researched
frank,
Marshall,
Davis and Obama,
I believe it is.
It's cracking and believe how inclusive
it is.
My Mom and dad are we talking about like
five years ago.
They thought,
that's crazy.
Let us see the film about it.
They saw it.
They were blown away,
but listen,
let me give you the big picture please.
The elite admit that they are studying
humanity like they're a breakaway
civilization.
They believe they're taking the best
ideas of humanity and building a
breakaway civilization of technocracy
show they can transcend us and I want
the public to know the decision has been
made dumb you down balkanize you turn
you against yourselves,
have regional wars,
play people off against each other and
then basically released bioweapons that
wipe out most of the population,
all the Atlantic transcendent.
Pause.
This right here.
Who are the elite like when you say the
elite,
who are these people and how do they get
together her?
Hold on a second.
How do they all agree?
Who Votes?
How do they decide is a bunch of towels?
Let me type a super billionaire
characters like run and shit.
So how do they get together and all
agree on the data side,
on agendas that will empower their
individual agendas and they're pretty
much let into those power structures
early on side of the men.
They are a group that was the Bilderberg
Group Club of Rome.
Bilderberg group.
It's the club of Rome Davis.
A club of Rome is a population reduction
group.
I mean,
if you can go to infowars.com
right now there's an article and a video
I cut about Oprah Winfrey.
I'm not saying it's a bad person or
she's part of a secret eugenics group.
Hold on a second.
Stop right there.
Only for opposite.
I'm not saying she's a bad person,
but he's part of a secret eugenics
group.
I'm a really good progressive.
I like killing weak people.
I'm just trying to thin the herd.
I'm a really good person though.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
Just absolutely.
So you can go there.
It's the truth about Oprah Winfrey.
Okay.
And.
And it just deals with it in the news.
Oprah Winfrey and secret meeting face.
He looks so serious.
I was like,
I toilet.
You think she's in secret meetings with
like the Bilderberg group or something?
She admits that to repo.
They admit on the news to reduce
population because we linked at first,
but let's play it know when someone
might hold please.
When someone like her says something
about reducing the amount of
illegitimate babies born or the amount
of babies that are born because there's
no birth control.
A lot of times those kind of statements
get construed into population control.
She's in the car and beat and people
start saying she's into population
control and that means she wants in the
secret meetings and she's pushing in and
she's tax exempt.
I'm not in those secret meetings.
Are you in those secret meetings?
You go to the failings that we like to.
Have you ever been in one of those
secret meetings?
I did check into one.
Do you hear what they said?
Yes.
Did they say they want to kill half the
people know what they say.
That was really shocking to Bohemian
Grove.
It wasn't.
I remember that dude.
That was the.
That was the real shit.
Fucking Jim Brown type shit dude.
I mean that is like if you want to go
back to like conspiracy theory,
fuel like that,
get excited about
something when you find out that there
really are a bunch of global elites to
get on this ranch and they got a fucking
giant stone owl and they burn a,
a bundle of wood in effigy and they all
were fucking masks and Shit and then you
actually have video footage of it and
there's weird sort of a ceremony they're
doing and whether or not they're
pretending you're pretending it is,
whatever,
whatever it is,
it's crazier and I was there and they
have exactly what it is.
Yeah,
go into that.
How did you sneak into the Bohemian
Grove?
That was amazing.
Well,
people always said it was a Saturday,
let me.
And it wasn't quite like that,
but we had an insider wanted to get me
in to actually see it and most people
aren't bad that go to it.
But the point is,
it's kind of a gateway into all of this.
It's amazing.
So this is you at Bohemian Grove and
you're in,
you're on the other side of liquor.
It looks like a little pond or
something.
Feel free to play it.
It goes beyond old care.
May fire make merriment with your dust
where you go,
no care.
It was so strange.
It was so bizarre.
Listening to that guy and the speaker
blaring out across the cronkite play it
put lit.
Let's.
Let's play of that was Walter cronkite.
Oh,
sounds like a play for high school.
It is.
It's all play,
but religion started that way as as,
as entertainment.
So what do you think?
This is just some really ancient ritual
that they're redoing.
Yeah.
I thought it was no big deal till I was
in the crown of old men that were
lavishing.
They were like,
they loved it.
I certainly had jackie lighting and
their pants.
Are you sure?
Are you projecting?
No,
no.
They were like to see.
What is it about people that love those
secret societies?
Like you remember that jfk speech about
secret societies who will not tolerate
them.
Yeah.
It's a fucking beautiful speech.
Well,
because I'll pull it up,
Jimmy,
pull up jfk speech about what power over
others that don't crave secret essence,
right?
They're looking for that secret place.
The most high.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
That's,
but that's just like you were talking
about pedophiles,
just like you know,
any other deviant.
Fuck yeah.
I just want to go eat a big pile of
steaks and drink some beer.
I say,
let's crank this up.
Ladies and gentlemen.
The very word secrecy is repugnant in a
free and open society and we are as a
people inherently and historically
opposed to secret societies to secret
oaths
and a secret proceeding.
I'm by myself,
but case please don't put this on.
I don't know if you've ever heard this
excessive and I'm just talking about
secret societies
of pertinent facts far outweigh the
dangers which are cited to justify it
even today.
There is little value in opposing the
threat of a closed society by imitating
its arbitrary restrictions.
Even today,
there is little value in ensuring the
survival of our nation if our traditions
do not survive with it and there is very
grave danger that an announced need for
increased security will be seized upon
by those anxious to expand its meaning
to the very limits of official
censorship and concealment.
That I do not intend to permit to the
extent that it's in my control and no
official of my administration,
whether his rank is high or low,
civilian or military should interpret my
words here tonight as an excuse to
censor the news to stifle dissent.
They knew it to cover up our mistakes or
to withhold from the press and the
public,
the facts they deserve to know,
but we are opposed around the world by a
monolithic and ruthless conspiracy that
relies primarily on covet means for
expanding its sphere of influence on
infiltration instead of invasion on
severity instead of elections on
intimidation instead of free choice on
guerrillas by night instead of armies by
day.
It is a system which has conscripted
vast human and material resources into
the building of a tightly knit,
highly efficient machine that combines
military,
diplomatic intelligence,
economic science comments,
political operations.
Its preparations are concealed,
not published.
It's mistakes have buried,
not headlined,
its dissenters.
A silenced not praised.
No expenditure is questioned.
No rumor is printed.
No secret is revealed.
No president should face public scrutiny
of his program.
For from that scrutiny comes
understanding and from that
understanding comes support or
opposition and both unnecessary.
I'm not asking your newspapers to
support an administration,
but I am asking your help approach and
the tremendous task of informing and
alerting the American people for I have
complete confidence
kilter.
That's a.
that's such a crazy speech because it's
him talking about the structures that
were already in place and about the
dangers of withholding information for
people and him being forthright as a
president in a way that we've never
heard before since like he's literally
talking,
Jill trump,
trump,
spending like that.
Now,
what a trump tell you.
Well,
we.
Let's just be clear.
He's talking about our own military
industrial complex that Eisenhower
warned about.
His outgoing predecessor.
He's talking about the Soviets there.
At the same time,
he was a really smart cookie.
The Eisenhower warning is one of the
creepiest things in human history.
Really?
Military,
industrial
complex.
Okay.
That sounded like he was talking about
communism.
Yeah.
Pull up our warns of the Military
Industrial Complex.
He did it,
but just go.
There's a clip that just has that
segment of it will be so yeah,
there was a lot.
He says there is a scientific
technocratic elite that has had the
control of all information about to shut
it down to the public and then they will
control the military,
so beware of the military.
He was in the military.
It was bad.
He said these 10 military industrial
eugenicist.
We're about to get control of it.
The scientific people are telling you
about.
See if you can find where it goes.
It Jamie,
this is the address right here is
we now stand 10 years past the midpoint
of a century that has witnessed for
major war among great naked
chose ride type in eisenhower military
industrial complex speech.
Yeah,
he's going to say it in here somewhere,
but it's a three minute speech at CCV,
Alex.
it seems like trump,
you know everybody,
a lot of smart people in different
points of their life,
they begin to realize how much,
how many lives they've been told.
They begin to wake up.
They're not totally woke up,
but they begin to wake up and then they
find out about nine slash 11,
but that don't believe all this other
shit and then they find out about this,
but they don't believe in all that other
shit.
Then they find out about that and then
at the very high level it's like the
dudes,
they're like,
yeah,
all this shit is true.
If you could follow the money,
it's probably true.
You might be wrong one or two or three
times,
but generally we're dealing with a
totally crooked situation.
That's what are they doing?
They're not stealing money from
corporations.
You steal money from a corporation.
They're going to come after you and kill
you.
Uh,
with what they're doing is the mastery
of stealing tax money.
That's what this is all about is just
stealing tax because nobody,
because nobody's going to go after tax
money.
You get all these programs and these
bills pass.
Let's play this good Jamie.
These military contracts,
the tax payers are paying for all this.
Their livelihood are all involved.
So is the very structure of our society
in the councils of government.
I'm going to guard against the
acquisition of unwarranted influence,
whether sought or unsought by the
military industrial complex.
The potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist.
We must never let the weight of this
combination in danger,
our liberties or democratic processes,
Jesus Christ.
Just let that out like it was so tight
because you think about this back in the
early days of radio,
in the early days of moving pictures
only finish.
Only the elite had access to this
technology.
Moving pictures radio right from the get
go,
right day one
right from day one.
It wasn't like your average guy was
trying to help humanity.
The guys who had this technology,
we're like,
damn.
They believe whatever the fuck we say
back in the day,
you'd listen to the radio,
those news reports or when the movie
pictures were from madness.
Yes,
that's what I'm talking about right from
the get go TV,
movies,
radio.
All of it was propaganda.
It never left.
Alex Jones is aliens involved in this
story.
Please talk about propaganda and movies
and Howard had ll limits.
Sir,
come to him.
Who was the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs?
All linen answers that is now just
google operation northwoods.
Oh,
I know about that.
Sure.
So they came to them and they said,
we're going to launch terror attacks in
America and start a war with the Soviet.
She's like,
well,
I know they're evil,
but we're not gonna do that.
So he fired him.
The JFK comes here.
The same guys had to make him do it.
He refuses.
So they kill him.
Well,
they wanted to have a drone jetliners
and blow them up and blame it on the
Cubans.
Nine slash 11.
They wanted to arm Cuban friendlies and
attack Guantanamo Bay.
They had a bunch of really crazy shit
planned.
When you realize what our operation
northwoods was and you realized that
this was signed by the joint chiefs of
staff,
it scares the shit out of you.
Is this real?
What?
We're all talking here.
We're talking here.
Does it?
Doesn't that scare the shit out of you?
Doesn't blow your mind that still today
it's 2017.
Doesn't it blow your mind that people
still think that nine slash 11 happened
the way it was we'll get to in
northridge is 100 percent crazy back to
the city classified 2000.
Well,
when people realize that that was a real
documents,
the US government plan to start war with
Russia and kill people and blow up movie
theaters,
attack US military basis,
kill American civilians,
capital,
kill American military food.
People hijack jets,
crashing them.
Have she,
I ain't get on board.
So fake plane lands are the real plane
lands.
A fake plane of tags was nine slash 11.
It's just bananas that someone would
actually sit down and write by patriots
six months before nine slash 11 trying
to stop it.
Really?
And that's not saying Islamic terrorism
real.
It's not saying bullshit.
Even did it.
Some super dark state group,
which Congress now has the 28 pages
vindicating 9:11
druker's that Shoddy Arabia with people
that they had gotten to convert to Islam
had paid off of their trillions and
trillions had joined them in some larger
plan to blame,
uh,
Iraq and other countries that were non
radical.
So Saudi Arabia,
you could take them over who,
who put together nine slash 11 shawnee
Rabia of the Muslims either with
anybody.
So they want to invade these other
countries.
The adder to happen in the US.
I mean the US wasn't involved.
Of course.
What?
What are you saying?
Who was involved?
Who were the key players that nine slash
11.
It's.
It's totally compartmentalized.
So you run a drill of the World Trade
Center and the Pentagon being attacked
on that day.
So the planes are flying around.
Oh this is just a.
That was a drill that was supposed to be
run that day.
It all
came out a drill that was about it.
A false false flags.
I.
It seems like,
okay,
we're going to do a false flag.
We need to set up a drill.
They need a drill going on.
It's 99 point nine percent of the
government wasn't involved because of
computers.
It was a test.
They get a 100 times worse now no one
will know because it's all remote.
Activated the jets by then.
We're all remote control.
Every jet for 25 years.
The big new ones has control morobe
control.
It's all.
It's crazy,
man.
There's jets now are unmanned.
Absolutely.
Well,
no,
there man.
It's just thinking to go on autopilot.
Stupid.
Damn man.
If you think about it,
it's remote controlled dumb thing they
said about the drone jetliners and they
were going to blow up that jetliner and
blame it on the Cubans.
That wasn't going to be a jetliner
filled with people.
It's going to be a drone.
So they have the capability.
In 1962 of doing that,
which is how did,
how did,
how did Robert F Kennedy or JFK,
his older brother who was Joe Kennedy
Junior die.
He was flying a fighter plane,
remote controlling to be 17.
Bloated with explosives as drones to
crash into Germany.
They had drums in World War II.
Jesus Christ.
They had drones in World War II.
What would they powered by Google cave
and how did Joe Kennedy Junior die?
He does secret mission over Germany.
My father.
No,
Joe Kennedy Junior.
Oh.
The crazy thing about the Kennedy's is,
is you know,
if you're.
A lot of times you see criminals come
from like a good family and then you can
see Robert Kennedy and John F Kennedy.
They come from gangs to his dad is a
gangster,
straight up mafia,
and then he has two kids.
They thought they had him under control
because he's from a Mafia family.
Here's the.
Here's the guy's named Joe Kennedy.
Isn't that weird?
Because it's like you're the opposite of
your parents,
like you want to go against your
parents.
So Robert Kennedy and John F Kennedy,
they went against that shit that that's
the only reason they were in there
because of the mob.
The mob supported Bob Stole Illinois for
and the mom supported John F Kennedy.
He was hanging out with Frank Sinatra.
Then all of a sudden he flipped and you
know what?
He stopped hanging out with Frank
Sinatra.
He started changing his ways.
Something flipped.
Did the did.
Did he have a kid that died or something
like that?
Is that something made him flip?
I thought I read something that could be
total bullshit,
but it could be that he had a son that
died and made them flip.
Go to Joe Kennedy Jr.
Here.
He was.
Killed.
The guys that could make you think
totally different when you're.
WHen you're a kid dies,
you're like,
fuck this.
I'm going with my soul.
Right?
You're like,
fuck this.
What could be worse?
Woke up.
My son already died.
I'm coming after you.
I'm coming after you liKe a fucking
apache
savage with nothing to lose.
So Joe Kennedy jr was killed in action
while serving as a land base patrol
bomber pilot in world war ii and with
posthumously awarded the navy cross,
Alex Jones throwing down.
Alex jusT doesn't doubt dude.
You're fucking.
You're on fire.
This was almost three hours of.
There's people out there.
There's nothing.
Don't just laying it down.
You're laying it down like game of
motherfucking thrones.
Yes you are.
All I know is there's people in the
government that want to empower people
and they're trying to do a good job and
I'm not anti government.
I want to have a good constitutional
government.
And the truth is,
I couldn't believe when in my pd
contacted me of the secret service.
The secret service came to me when I was
at the rnc.
So I'd like to number one passage.
Nobody had read passages.
I'd go behind the scenes.
Nobody stopped me,
but back in the back deal,
the secret service,
like in their ships,
go,
hey alex,
come here will tell you something about
hillary.
Give us a contact number.
The next month we're going to contact
you.
About a month later I get a contract.
They go,
can you come to it?
There's nothing digital.
He'd come down and meet at this place.
So I go down and meet,
meet one of other people as well.
Because where they were,
it was like they were hitting.
Both sides were operation and they said
to me,
hillary has seizures.
Like every 30 minutes she's got an
ambulance,
is black.
She falls down all the time,
just heavier people at her event.
He'll see her falling down.
She's covering it up.
Well sure enough,
a month,
an outside on air.
A month later she falls down in front of
the cameras.
We had footage wait before in cleveland
again,
st louis,
she was back to,
oh,
it was a key battleground and she.
She was like for an hour in this
emergency tent with,
with ambulances and stretchers,
so I'm telling you,
I mean I've got real sources that really
care about what's happening in this
country and everything.
They told me it Was dead on.
You know,
what's scary about my government lakes.
Let's go.
Go back to the hillary thing was very
bizarre because nobody was supposed to
mention it like you weren't supposed to
mention that she was fallen down.
Said,
we're like monya.
They said,
oh,
she had pneumonia.
Let me tell you something.
I've had pneumonia.
You know what I haven't done.
I haven't ever walked and just fallen
down while I'm walking.
Really frayed as the background and then
comment on it because this is key.
It's known that in 2012 when she fell on
her head and she's got a severe
concussion that was worrying for my
sources,
but yeah,
she's in the hospital for a year.
Then she was.
Yeah,
she was fucked up for six whole months
according to clinton to bill,
so she looks like hell,
we don't know where she is.
And then meanwhile I'm told,
hey,
she's falling down all the time.
She looks like hell on tv.
And then secret service says,
look,
you've got the people,
get up off your ass and follow her.
So we follow her in like five cities.
We didn't catch it.
We were in New York.
they sneak her out.
She falls down having epilepsy every 15,
20 minutes,
30 minutes.
The poInt is is my intel was good.
They gave us good info.
So what are the elite thinking?
They're going to put somebody in
with epilepsy.
That's all I'm saying.
But do you think that it was just the
idea was she can hold it together.
Just anything rather than get as soon as
they.
If they just want her to get her
through,
get all those girls like oh my god,
everything is great.
And then they pass all these
motherfucking bills,
and it was,
it seemed to me that when all this was
happening that people so desperately
wanted to not look at it because the
alternative was trump.
It wasn't that they were taking an
objective look at it and go,
wow,
maybe she shouldn't be blacking out.
And then you consideR that massive head
injury that she had in 2012,
which is real.
It's a fact.
You don't like it when you bring that up
though,
because they think if you bring that up,
you're going to change people's opinion
and you're going to help trump win.
Can I just spend two minutes talking to
your audience?
Which,
which camera is about trump.
That one,
just auto claim to have all the answers
and I'm not here to boost Your trump
because I'm tied to his wagon.
If I attack trump,
I'd make more money.
This isn't about money.
It's about the truth.
Trump really is trying to cut taxes and
make people successful and wealthy.
He really does care about the average
person.
The elite have set up a plan to slave
people to make folks poor.
And all I'm asking you to do is get past
thinking that you're part of the
establishment or you're smart because
you're anti trump.
I'm asking you to actually look at
what's really been going on and
understand that democrats,
republicans come and go.
Some are good,
some are bad.
The whole power structure has been
against trump for a very serious reason.
Trump is coming after them and really is
attempting to bring down this whole
global system.
And that's where all hell's breaking
loose.
So I just want your viewers and
listeners know I'm not some political
hack.
Like you said earlier,
I used to be against bush.
I Wish obama would have been real.
the point is they got to obama with
trump.
He doesn't give a damn.
They admit they're offering money.
Everything.
He doesn't listen.
So you think what trump could or excuse
me,
what obama could have been his who he
was when he was running for office,
that he was this radical element of
change,
hope and change.
He wanted to close down guantanamo bay.
He's wanting to do all these things.
But one of the posters in the back,
during his administration,
the dea decided to not take marijuana
off the schedule.
One,
everybody knows it's not scheduled yet.
Was the cover for schedule one means no
medical use.
He's start looking at the time it means
that's what it means to be schedule one.
It's crazy that marijuana is schedule
one when it's the most useful out of all
the different,
various illegal smart you are joe.
You smoke marijuana quite a bit and
you're still smart guys.
Definitely not bad for just smelling it
and I can't even think here.
I know you can't listen.
Let's get serious.
I'm telling you,
it's trump about what are those
conversations about?
Let the people knoW.
I mean trump really wants to make poor
people rich.
He really wants you to feed
collectivism.
Collectivism.
He hates all the bashing the family and
what's collected.
All the new world order.
Collectivism is this thing.
And like you're not an individual.
You're like part of a group.
And truMp can't stand that.
He can't stand.
Seeing as a businessman,
business
deals where China has like 35 percent
currency tariffs on us.
There's no way he could even compete and
they're shutting off our power plants
with regulations but not theirs.
Why do we do that then?
What is the reason why?
Because our elites under,
at,
quite frankly,
under,
under kissinger and,
and,
and of course,
uh,
you know,
the president who was in that
administration,
nixon,
dave made a one sided deal for a leech
to go make deals with China and their
billion plus slaves.
I'll say that condescendingly,
they're like slaves to leverage out the
west,
the whole world's industry and trump
doesn't like those ones side of deals.
And he's saying,
listen,
we're not going to impoverish America,
we're going to empower America and we're
going to actually use american power to
promote freedom worldwide.
So let me get this straight for guys
like me that,
I mean,
all trump's does little promises.
So what you're saying is,
in layman's terms,
the elite,
the people in power,
the people that had the green light
power to sign these treaties,
they were maybe offered a couple meal
here,
couple meal there,
and sign this to sell the country out so
that they could make $10,000,005
billion thing like that is something
that you asked,
got colonized by corporate takeover
artists and trump at the end said f you.
So we're goIng to take their whole
global system.
They built for nothing.
Take it away from them and have the true
new american millennium,
not the new century.
You listened to his.
I don't know if we got the time.
If you want to play this 18 minute share
to the union,
we could start or not.
Definitely not going to play that.
Fidel,
his,
his global,
uh,
inauguration speech.
He lays the whole beautiful bitch out.
And so if anybody ever wanted to
actually have somebody trying to make
them great and wealthy and powerful,
it's donald j.
Trump.
That's why the whole eat the whole power
structure,
hollywood,
all the pedophiles,
every damn demon,
every pot belly,
one inch fucker,
you know they are all against trump
because he is pro human and he wants to
dominate all these people.
It is an active alpha male.
He wants.
It's of the ego every now and then.
Every now and then we can help them run
for office.
It.
He talks to you and he calls you are
right.
I mean,
that's crazy.
He uses the other people.
You know,
people think,
I don't know Alex Jones.
They believe the mainstream media.
When they tried to crucify him and say
he's at butler quack,
and he said,
well,
alex,
what you need?
Honestly,
if someone had temporary you,
you,
you need me right next to you All the
time to balance powerful.
This is you being right there that
you're like the fucking need to calm
them down on your lap.
You got a bio suit on and you got to
fucking ray gun.
You're like,
okay,
we need this alien to for to benefit
humanity,
but I got to put this goddamn bio suit
on because he's going crazy.
Just gotta kinda steer them
occasionally.
Just you get out,
you get on rants and you'll see you'll
connect four or five different
non-related subjects,
but that's,
that's.
It's beautiful.
It's not a bad guy that does.
Does that just go rent after rent,
after rent,
after rent with no teleprompters.
Only a guy that could do is right.
I'm actually very pleased that,
that joe has finished all my sentences
and knows more than I do and it sits
over there acting like he doesn't know
all this.
I no,
no more than you can make them more than
you know,
just as much as every document,
every secret program.
He knew all about it,
you know,
it waSn't bullshitting the whole time.
You've been fucking.
You are building.
Listen mike,
hold on.
Cigarette about bill hicks.
He's a great comic.
Micro scopic,
bacterial penis atomic split.
The goddamn critical mass compared to
Joe rogan.
I'm nothing.
I'm nothing and I've talKed so much shit
about conspiracy theories that I feel
like I need to shut the fuck up because
I don't.
I don't want any trouble asking
questions of the universe.
It's questioning on your own,
the mystery and not Just receiving the
priest class stuff.
Yes.
I'm not trying to.
I walked away from my podcast.
Nobody.
I thought nobody was listening,
but now people want me to go back.
I'm like,
I thought nobody,
but listen.
I don't want to be a conspiracy guy like
you.
I don't want to be that,
but I listened to you and you are my
canary in the goddamn coma.
As long as you're alive,
I feel like I'm okay to say shit,
but I'll tell you this.
Every time I come to do the fight
companion,
gi joe rogan experience,
I swear to god.
I tell myself this,
this fight companion,
no motherfucking conspiracy stairs.
let's just live live.
I called joke and I and I called him
after a fight companions.
They go,
I can't believe I did it again,
joe.
I can't believe,
but suddenly something in me wants to
help people.
For some reason and a lot of times my
enemies like,
fuck them,
make a fucking,
you know what I mean?
Fuck them.
And I'm like,
damn,
if I just walk away because I'm
compelled,
but I'm not trying to make money off
conspiracy theories.
I gave have a conspiracy theory podcasts
right now and it would be okay,
but I'm not even trying to do that.
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to be that guy.
Don't want to be you,
but something inside me when the fucking
mic stand in someone's question and I'm
like,
I got a son and I want to make sure did
I fucking do everything I can for him
because I don't want him.
I don't want to leave him with some shit
that I couldn't change.
So inside of me,
I'm like on the fence all the time.
Therefore,
when you're overzealous,
overzealous and you actually turn people
the wrong way and they look at any
conspiracies is being proposed or even
the ones that are real like sand dusky
liked the catholic church like many
other ones before.
There's a ton of them.
Liked hastert.
Who was the speaker of the fucking
house?
Pedophile.
There's been a lot of frank,
so it's really critical,
but hold on a second.
Hold on a second,
eddie.
It's really critical Whenever you
discussing any of these things and you
get all the fucking ducks in order
before you pick a side,
it's super important because anytime you
make some crazy claim and it's connected
to a conspiracy theory and it proves to
be Wrong,
it fucks with all the ones that are not
personally.
I'm all rIght.
People saying I'm bill hicks.
People show the others saying that.
It's like their eye hurts me.
They're that dumb that they don't know
my own personality.
It's a joke.
Me,
man,
it's on reddit.
Shit.
No,
I get it.
It's unfortunate they're having fun,
but let's get to know.
Some of them are serious.
No.
Yeah,
but no.
Let me ask you something really quickly
is very important.
Let me ask you a super important.
I feel like I was,
I was trying to say this earlier,
but we had to go back and finish up
mouth,
but this is very important.
I,
uh,
I teach jujitsu.
I got students all over the world.
I got schools all over the world.
Um,
I have all my students.
I'm a west star tool to wake up,
you know,
that's like a metaphor.
I'm a conspiracy theory,
like at different times.
Some are just into me for jujitsu,
but they believed the cNn site 100
percent,
it takes him three years and they're
like,
oh shit.
They started smoking weed and damn there
all,
all over the conspiracy faCt,
everybody awakens at a different point.
No matter how smart they are,
you cAn,
you can get your master's,
your phd,
you could be,
oh,
I'm a scientist or whatever,
but you're working for the government
and you ain't thinking about you.
But listen,
listen.
Do you think donald,
do you think Donald Trump is in the
middle of an awakening,
awakening from a hundred percent real?
He's like,
is he in the middle of an awakening?
Yes,
because he could easily have been a
billionaire tumor two years ago who,
who bought all the mainstream shit,
but he was a billionaire.
He didn't give a fuck about the
mainstream shit.
He's cutting deals blowing up,
but now you know at a certain point,
no matter where you are,
no matter how smart you are,
you awaken a little,
little by little trump.
Donald trump knows which way the wind's
going,
and as julius caesar in,
in,
in the famous play by william
shakespeare of julius caesar,
there is a tide in the affairs of malmo
taken at the flood,
leads onto fortune,
or as mark twain said,
in the beginning of patriots have scarce
man hated and feared scorn,
but a time when has caused exceeds it
costs.
Nothing has Joined a patriot.
so here's what's happening right now.
There's a major shift happening and
trump really wants to empower the
people.
Globalism is anti human,
and so all I'm trying to get at is,
is that some really big things are
happening in this world and people
watching shouldn't be conservative or
liberal.
CAn you stop?
Can I stop you for a moment?
What do you.
When you say globalism,
what do you mean by that?
Please define that.
Globalism is like neo colonialism,
but it's colonialism over humans,
individuals,
government states,
old world,
new world.
It's worldwide.
Colonialism,
rothchild,
but financially it's monopoly is the
dominant populations and create
centralized systems of monopolies in
controlling wants to innovation.
It wants to end up where mobility,
globalism is.
Corporate world government.
Why do they want to stop innovation?
Because they see it as a bourbon.
They see it as what they call it,
disruptive technology and humanity.
So powerful.
You've already got a monopoly.
So is this a recent consideration after
the unit?
It's been.
Internet has been in global is bigger
than that,
but yes we are.
Part of that's true.
Since they've already got control,
they want competition to end.
They're in control.
They don't want challengers.
They've seized control of the human
psyche,
human development to the stars.
They've got it all.
I think they're getting rid of humanity
and becoming gods.
Whatever dimension they're tuned into,
told them that.
So they want debates to end and they
want authoritarianism.
They want to see what would happen
there.
Bolt,
how is Donald Trump going to stop this?
A bulk came off the,
uh,
going crazy.
Cns making bolts come up and hoping it
happens.
Alex,
how are you hoping they have to do with
blocking?
Chances are energy siphons there
vampiric actions of course,
so if he actually cuts taxes to poor
people and middle class and gets rid of
tax incentives for really rich,
he's not coming after the rich,
but from a conservative perspective that
republicans are cheering and so is that
what he wants to do?
He wants to cut taxes for everybody
except the rich.
He's gonna.
Encourage them.
Really?
Oh yeah.
That seems like the opposite of what a
rich guy would do.
Right,
but he understands like Henry Ford did,
you got to sell a car where people can
afford to buy it.
You got to pay your employees where they
can buy it.
He wants real prosperity.
He doesn't.
This is trying to get off in his.
In his limousine.
Robin by burnout old towns.
Does is has been announced this tax
plan.
Yeah.
So jamie,
see if he could pull up what it says.
that's fascinating.
I wonder if that will change people's
opinions if that really does happen to
people can save a significant amount of
money in taxes.
The problem,
the globalist admit they want a global
consolidation,
they want a global downturn to break.
Her buddies will and accept all the new
taxes and regulations.
And so trump is racing.
Remember they had for eight years he
represented interest,
but it was only the big banks.
Trump said we're going to keep zero
percent for one year even though he's
against it,
but for poor people to get zero percent
interest.
Who cares?
It's all fee out anyways.
The banks lose the money.
It's all just write offs.
They're killing it all now.
And raising,
raising taxes,
trump tax reform that will make America
great again.
The goals of Donald Trump,
number one tax relief for middle class
America in order to achieve the american
dream that people keep more money in
their pockets and increase the after tax
wages.
Number two,
uh,
simplify the tax code to reduce
headaches.
Americans face in preparing their taxes
and let everYone keep more of their
money.
So he's traveled.
Plan,
he's already implemented it though.
or 12 days in,
we've already got.
He's doing.
So if you're single and you earn less
than $25,000
or married and jointly earned less than
$50,000,
you will not owe any income tax shit.
Holy shit.
The taxes on portable,
that removes nearly 75 million
households all over 50 percent of the
income tax roles.
Other posts,
they get a new one page form to send to
the irs saying,
I win those who would otherwise.
Oh,
how crazy is that?
They get to save a new one page form to
send to the irs saying,
I win those.
Those who would otherwise a owe income
tax will save an average of nearly
$1,000
each.
Yeah,
it's not that big.
If you're the lowest bracket that pays
taxes,
you basically don't pay taxes.
You don't want people to pay in.
Taxes are for rich people.
Rich,
you pay big tips.
You get it like these people need money.
But look at this statement.
No business of any size from a fortune
500 to a mom and pop shop to a
freelancer living job to job will pay
more than 15 percent of their business
income in taxes.
That's just plan this lower rate makes
corporate investments inversions
unnecessary by making america's tax rate
one of the best in the world.
Holy shit.
We have one of the highest rates,
so nobody wants to be here.
No family will have To pay the death
tax.
Holy shit.
You know about this deliver man that
trump is for real.
He's totally.
You earned and saved that money for your
family and not the government.
You paid taxes on it when you earned it.
That is so buick immigrants.
His athletic applicant is a beautiful
tax plan.
That death tax is disgusting.
So like if you left money for your kid,
they would take half your money.
They take some dumb giant chunk of it
and he's saying that's not gonna happen
anymore.
That alone,
that's a beautiful thing.
That's a very good thing.
So trump has painted this painting land
70 of them and like they're like pushing
by families with kids like carrie,
carrie,
like yelling at families.
Just want going forward.
They like literally pushed by like
hispanic families and black people
screaming kkk.
And I looked at him on tape or just
going like what feels good for people to
have a clear enemy and if they can
justify in their mind you're a white
supremacist or anybody on the alt right
is a racist or twelfth kkk.
And I heard he's a rapist.
Everyone's marching on the streets.
That's what.
Well,
there's also a bunch of people that are
looking for some sort of solidarity
pumped.
Maybe they were.
Maybe They thought that hillary was a
better choice and maybe they got excited
that they could get together and join up
and walk the streets.
Anytime you can get people to get
together for a common good in their mind
at least.
And no one gets arrested,
that's a good thing.
Probably no traffic for a lot of people
and made it annoying.
What would you do if like almost half
the time you go out to eat or in a
grocery store,
someone slaps you in the back and
telling me that happens to you.
Right?
Well I wonDer where it's like they're
interdimensionally connected.
Like why is it always boom,
you're a loser.
Slap you in the face of the back of the
head.
It's like,
how are they so with that was the
greatest thing you've ever said.
No,
I'm serious.
He just didn't fight it.
A door for people going who you're a
loser and then try to slap you in the
back of the head.
It's going to happen again.
You started to human meme care.
The point is,
how are they so sync?
Okay,
here's the deal.
Well,
You have women going,
allah akbar,
why love god by the media,
by the media,
and I'm out there peacefully videotaping
him.
The saturday after trump's inauguration
in dc before I leave and they're like,
eff you white male.
They're all white women.
I'm all out and they put hats on.
They burke is screaming,
I'm going to join jihad.
You'll never stop me.
I'm like,
I'm not going to cut your genitals
often.
Put you on a slave block.
I don't get where.
I've never done anything to women and
all these weird ass women include the dc
police were letting people attack us.
They were wearing these pink hats and
then they get attacked.
Praising.
Yeah.
Somebody was saying that you were drunk.
That's not true,
right?
Absolutely not.
I didn't think so.
No,
no.
The truth is,
the headline was Alex Jones kicked out
of inauguration.
They have people blocking the hindrances
because they had it all fenced off.
You could get in.
Yeah,
it was.
The whole thing is,
it's,
it's very,
uh,
the whole movement is very aggressive.
You know,
it's like a response to what they think
is a aggressive,
you know,
you're all over.
They're slick asking questions.
Mr john,
we have heard.
Let's be serious.
What is your real worldview or the
nature of consciousness on this planet
and intergalactic space?
I've been a been a really honest today
and a lot of true answers.
So metaphysically,
what is the secret of the universe?
This is what I think there was a little,
a organism that was just recently
discussed.
We did it,
I think yesterday,
and they think it was one of the very
first organisms that was the precursor
to what we eventually became.
And then all biological life,
all like living,
walking things came out of this one
multicell organism,
right?
Yeah.
So one thing I think as that happened,
whatever hundreds of millions of Years
ago,
I don't know what the number is,
but whatever,
however long,
billions of years that happened to go,
if we keep going in that same direction,
whatever we are now,
which is going to be totally
unrecognizable just a few hundred years
from now or a few thousand years from
now,
or if we just do it biologically a
million years from now,
but I think that if human beings managed
stay alive for a long period of time and
not blow each other up,
we're on the cusp of figuring out how to
manipulate our very beings like to the
point where we're not going to be people
anymore.
It's just going to chAnge.
That's it.
Yeah.
Humanity is at the crossroads and that's
my message today.
The elite have decided they think the
course of our evolutIon,
I'm here to say,
shouldn't we decided to have a debate
about it?
Well,
I don't have.
Some of the experiences is a great place
for the people have this insatiable need
for innovation.
They're fascinated by it.
They want the newest phone,
even though their phone works perfect.
Is that they just want it.
They have this desire.
It's a weird thing.
It's just like we were talking about
like these,
these things aren't designed to make you
addicted to them.
You're just addicted to them.
They're designed well.
There's a weird sort of connection that
we have to this technology and I think
it's because of what marshall mcluhan
said before.
I think it's because of what marshall
mcluhan said that human beings are the
sex organs and the machine world.
I really think that's what they're
doing.
I think all of this integration and all
this innovation of all this kind of the
primary prevailing does compelling focus
on technology is because evolutionarily
that's where our biology goes.
It goes to technology because it can
manipulate it at a far faster rate.
Our evolution,
and I hear what you're saying,
biomechanically genetically through
round cells,
not square silicon.
We do it more beautifully and strongly.
I agree with what you're saying.
Overall,
I don't think it's an either or.
Alice shouldn't just expect alex.
I don't think it's either.
Just accept it.
They're going to be able to do shit in
both ways,
whether it's integrating combinators
longer,
I'm going to do it.
It's going to happen.
The point is going to be screaming for a
hundred years from the public needs to
know this.
Yeah,
so I think the larger debate about it,
well they do.
They are learning about it.
It's just something that you have to
seek out and it's really all the
information is control.
I don't know about that.
The information about is about
innovation and and artificial
intelligence to up.
They're letting a lot out of this
constant study.
If you were tony fucking Montana running
the planet,
would you let that shit out of what you
keep it for you,
but eddie,
there's not.
Tony Montana is not running science.
The thing is these scientists are almost
all involved in universities and
different studies and they worked on the
phds and trying to make a name for
themselves.
They're exploring all these different
possibilities and then big companies
that can profit off of it and billions
and billions of dollars like sony or
apple or any of these other companies,
these people up and they're fucking.
Hold on a second there thing is to
innovate and make money.
That's what they're there for.
That's what they do in the envelope and
technology,
but they're not.
Tony Montana.
do you understand this?
You're talking about two different
things.
You're talking about some utopia?
No,
no.
Talking about what it's trying to to
benefit the point.
Talking about what intel.
Here's people who makes iphone,
doesn't matter.
We're having a real discussion about the
future of the technological system of
humanity.
They don't want that discussion.
She'll this things that whether it's joe
or Alex Jones or eddie bravo,
we're all having on the joe rogan
experience a dIscussion the elite are
having right now in Hawaii right now
with zuckerberg.
I know for a fact the elites are meeting
with zuckerberg in
facebook to alkali,
but the whole point is they're having
this meeting.
He owns facebook now and we should
discuss what's happening.
Is facebook part of the illuminati now?
You know he's a bear shit in the woods
part of it.
Come on,
aren't you?
Look at alex that that profile.
I know you do.
I know you folks off.
Hey,
the big issues of the world is he never
asked me about ronald reagan.
I want to know about aliens.
I keep coming back to that because I
want to know what do they know about
aliens?
What are you wearing?
What are they real?
Okay.
I'll tell you right now,
and what I say is not political and it's
not from my particular perspective,
from the known knowledge in the
universe.
We live in a third dimensional plane.
We can see the planets and the galaxies.
The sun's hundreds of billions of
galaxies,
photographed universes.
We live in an amazing space.
Time continuum.
The elites believe that it's not in the
third dimension that we're mainly
receiving transmissions.
Ships don't arrive from elvis and
tourists or gt prime for wherever
they're coming from or meal.
Jeez.
They come here to inter interdimensional
gates that are much closer through fold
space,
and so we have to discuss the different
influences there in the universe and on
fact that we have freewill and we decide
what we want.
I don't believe in any of this.
I'm simply telling you what the elites
believe.
So they believed thAt there's another
dimension and these beings are
mentioned.
They need baby blood,
right?
They need something.
They need to tune in.
Let me tell you,
oh,
we're really powerful.
Were made the image of our creator.
Our brain is able to tune into the
lowest dimension,
the hIghest.
At mentioned,
humans are basically really powerful
creatures that can live right close to
sons that are highly radioactive.
nothing else can live as close with very
short lives because we're like a hive
organism that actually lives second to
second in the space time continuum.
She's like 100 years,
it's a second,
and we transmit our data up to be able
to live next to likely stargate jump
gates that are,
that are sons.
So because we live so close to these
sons,
we only have milliseconds to be alive,
so we're actually a hive organism that
keeps transmitting up to the next
species in our,
in our,
in a hierarchical system,
and then down below us.
So we're alive right now in this
continuum and we're trying to progress
and,
and make things better.
And the elites are trying to make sure
that we don't doubt into that incredible
knowledge we've got as a species.
It basically dies a species so that
we're not competitors on the next level
as the bible says of their dimensional
plane.
But you don't believe that.
You're just saying that's what they.
Oh yes,
exactly.
I'm not calculating anything.
What do you believe?
No,
I mean,
I believe in research.
do you think that I believe in research
to.
Do you think that there is something
from other dimensions that can access
us?
Uh,
this,
we are other dimensions.
The third dimension is only one limited
plane in a larger spectrum.
Part of that spectrum.
Well,
let's just say we're not in Kansas
anymore.
Alex.
Have you ever done dmt?
No.
Do you want to.
I don't need to go to every night I go
to sleep.
I believe that he's done.
It's like he's on natural dmt.
Definitely on something man.
For sure.
And I got a question for you.
You know how this is,
this is kind of off the cuff a little
bit off track,
off the beaten path,
but you know how the cia has always been
involved in hollywood and make movies
and you know,
like zero dark 30 and you know,
all of these movies that are clearly
propaganda movies,
you know what I mean?
Hold on.
MosT like even movies you think they
weren't propaganda,
but they are.
They like the superhero movies.
How they're just all the plots and the
evil.
Oh they're going to build a bomb and all
that is.
Is there whistleblowers within hollywood
that are making movies?
Just like in Brazil it was a martial
arts were outlawed.
So the people,
the people that were about the truth,
they were like doing dance,
but they were disguising them.
Our clients.
Is there a filmmaker?
Are.
They're filmmakers like that out there
that are trying to help humanity with
the basis of their films or is it all
perfectly?
It was like anything else.
There's good people and bad people and I
don't think hollywood overall is bad.
Which,
which movies are the good ones.
Tell him because I watched star wars.
I'm like,
is this the bad one?
That's propaganda.
Street movies are good ones.
The good ones.
which ones are the ones I should go
deacon nights.
what about like when a hangover one
comes out,
let me tell you.
That's not because anybody that didn't
like hangoveR.
Go ahead.
I'm oNly the name of like one part of
the shadow government,
whiCh is all the intellectuals of
America.
So those people are on trump's sIde now.
Yeah,
and that's the first time ever.
Well,
the cia has never been perfect,
so they must've been with bush,
right?
Because bush used to be the presidency.
I senior george herbert walker,
so he was head of the cia.
Here's the deal.
The cia was shut up supposedly to defend
the republic and do all this stuff.
It got hijacked by multinational
interest.
It's been retaken and they're cleaning
the shia out right now.
Are you serious?
That's fucking breaking god damn news
shit up on info wars.
The cio as cleaning house.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Why isn't that the headline news on info
wars right now,
the rock tee shirt,
a lot of folks did really,
really crazy things for the cia.
The cia does like the fighting
and they were all pissed off and they
were portrayed by infiltrators inside
the cia.
really bad stuff that went on,
but right now there is a counter kid
within the cia going on and cleaned them
out while they're definitely trying.
Jesus christ.
I like what I'm hearing.
We'll see what happens,
but are you?
Are you happy about the futures
succeeds?
Within three years,
you're going to hear major cancer cures
announced.
You're goiNg to hear a new energy
systems announce.
You're going to hear a new companies
announced they've suppressed all this
stuff and trump what good people want to
empower humanity.
They believe in the species and the
planet and big stuff's about how god
damn crazy would be if trump became a
hero.
He is,
he wrote about,
but do you know how crazy it was?
Hit the.
The country accepted him.
If they figured this out after.
If this is all true.
This all comes through exactly as you're
saying,
which I really have no idea if you're
right
and you know what you could play right
now.
How about that bill clinton clip that
you played where he's talking about
vetting immigrants like more hardcore
than trucks and we're going to all that.
everybody.
How do you pull that?
How does clinton and
bill clinton and hillary promote wall
and the wall's got halfway agree,
disagree with them on the wall?
Because people do a ladder over.
It's metaphysical.
It's like we're a country.
We're allowed to have this.
Mexico has one.
Canada has one account.
Why can't we?
The big thing is just deport people that
are on welfare.
We need people from Mexico and Russia
and Japan and just to poor people that
are on welfare.
It's the only deport,
the poorest ones.
The ones that can't say if you won't do
anything and you're calm here.
Yeah,
we'll call out.
Okay,
so when they come over here,
you're saying give him a chance,
but then once if they try to stay on
welfare,
that wasn't always sell more shit or not
sounds
good.
In 1995,
listen,
this is in 1995,
just totally in the states,
most heavily affected,
but in every place in this country are
rightly disturbed by the large numbers
of illegal aliens entering our country.
The jobs they home might otherwise be
held by citizeNs or legal immigrants.
The public service they use impose
burdens on our taxpayers.
that's why our administration has moved
aggressively to secure our borders more
by hiring a record number of new border
guards by deporting twice as many
criminal aliens is ever before.
By cracking down on illegal hiring,
by borrowing welfare benefits to illegal
aliens that I will present to you,
we will try to do more to speed the
deportation of illegal aliens who were
arrested for crimes to better identify
illegal aliens in the workplace as
recommended by the commission headed by
former congresswoman Barbara Jordan.
We are a nation of immigrants,
but we are also a nation of laws.
It is wrong and ultimately self
defeating for a nation of immigrants to
permit the kind of abuse of our
immigration laws we have seen in recent
years,
and we must do more to stop it if that
doesn't vindicate fucking trump on all
fence shit,
but it also makes you realize what a bad
motherfucker bill clinton was.
His trump can make a speech that bill
clinton was a good guy.
Hit me.
He hit each other walk.
If you're a chick out there marching,
talking about the wall and you just
heard that,
that was not a real realize.
I'm giving you a chance.
Admit you were pumped.
It's okay.
everybody gets powerful power punch.
But from this point on,
shut the fuck up about it will power.
That's not.
No.
Okay.
Let's,
uh,
that's about it.
A time.
Take one dose.
If I give you full power,
you're going to be in the hit.
It's five.
We're going to wrap this up.
We got it.
We did a good job.
Ask one more question.
Go ahead.
One more.
I,
you know me,
I'm fucking fascinated with the
conspiracy.
They're just like you.
Every night.
Dudes are watching fights in boxing.
I'm listening to conspiracy theories
every fucking night.
When I go to bed,
I listen to Alex Jones everyday,
everyday.
The one thing that gets that I don't
get.
I get the establishment,
I get the illuminati,
I get all that shit,
but then there's ronald reagan.
Every now and then you have dr steve
progenic on your show and he's talking
about some serious conspiracy diaries.
All this shit is confirming everything.
He's deep in the cia confirming shit,
but then when they talk about ronald
reagan,
they talk about like he was the last
great president and I thought that
actor,
the guy was an fbi informant,
isn't any,
so god damn establisHment ronald reagan.
I don't get that.
Explain ronald reagan.
I mean george senior was the vice
president,
director of the cia and he just seems
like the salt,
but this is once in a while.
Okay.
ExplAin ronald reagan if you want to end
the transmission.
Let's explain.
Ronald reagan.
Go ahead.
We're just joking around punching
earlier.
No,
no,
it's okay.
But his question wanting more hours.
He wants to know about ronald reagan.
Hold off because I can trust telling me
the movies.
Okay.
Ronald reagan.
We're not in some blood fests with
reagan,
but after all the obama globalization,
it's like I'm astounded.
Good thing.
Reagan ran against george herbert
walker.
Bush said he was global,
a cfr world government.
Then they told him at the convention,
okay,
you won,
but we're going to not let you have the
domination if you don't want to.
Put a herbert walker bush,
and then a year end they shooting.
They just released that guy and so all
this stuff went.
Oh shit,
I didn't know.
So reagan didn't get his agenda through
and they tagged on Iran contra all this
other stuff.
Reagan actually wanted to get rid of the
irs and a bunch of good stuff.
So yeah,
I noticed the anticommunist.
He was running against George Bush.
He beat him and then when he got the
presidential nomination for the
republican party,
they made him.
They forced him to take the drug store
witH forced way.
None of the ronald reagan and I wanted
to believe in obama,
but he's a total level of a new tax.
Things crazy.
Once you think of that,
it's pretty radical.
Joe Got mad at us trading punches.
Trump on trump.
Give me.
Took me up people.
There's people out there that think
trump is racist and they think he's a
sexist at a whoremonger closer
whoremonger sexist and I'm not.
Okay,
well good for him.
A lot of people do.
Okay,
so you think he's a good guy?
I know trump's a good guy.
He at.
What he's done is he's delivered like no
president ever.
Alright.
Everybody.
So everybody wants to find some reason
to hate him and some reason to figure
out a way to get him out of office,
but we shouldn't.
We at this point.
I mean he,
he won their game,
right?
There's a popularity contest.
He won the popularity contest and that's
really what being president is.
Figuring out a way to get the most
amount of people to say,
I like you better.
I mean That's really what it is.
And he's the first truly popular person
who's really good at manipulating the
media to win a popularity contest.
Everybody before him had just been a
politician.
He's the first guy that's actually
famous that then became presidents two
point.
Oh,
it's never happened before.
Been a half hours.
So reagan,
that was the California.
It's 5:00.
That's the only two and a half hours.
Yeah,
but the point being that he's.
He wasn't that famous,
famous like Donald Trump.
I don't think he was famous movie star
reagan.
Are you cutting?
True,
but I don't think he was a big movie
star.
I think he was Christian Slater.
She probably doesn't.
Trump wasn't a movie star.
No fence.
Christian slater.
I loved you in blade.
Hey,
who's in dade county jail?
He was in blade,
right?
Ms dot christine slade and blood job.
No,
stephen dorff was.
Well it was.
So.
It was ronald reagan.
Did he get his.
I'm ready to end this right now,
but I'm telling you once in a lifetime
interview,
we haven't got that real questions.
We're only two and half hours in five,
three and a half hours.
When we go live underneath what?
Thirty will I have a 1:30.
We're sitting in the chair before austin
time.
Look at the clock right next to you.
See,
it's 5:00.
Yeah,
fine.
I'm wearing louis.
You want to talk?
All I know is that most of your
listeners should know,
really told you the real truth of what
I've researched.
You shouldn't believe him as sham,
their total corporate whores.
What do you think is gonna happen?
How do you think this is going to play
out now that you think this sort of
silent,
bloodless coup is taking place and this
guy has gotten through this net that had
been set there to make sure that no one
other than the people that were already
inside the system could ever run it,
so he got through.
That was a.
He's running it now.
We're going to wrap up once in a
lifetime situation.
Trump isn't perfect.
He really wants to empower humanity.
All of us have to work hard,
be involved here.
Our views,
put out our ideas and just move forward
with the airplane to try to assassinate
trump.
You think so?
Oh god.
They're demonizing him saying killing
them all.
Fascinating.
For real,
or do you mean assassInated him
publicly?
Like politically
assassinated.
They want to politically destroy his
name and they want to politically also
try to kill him.
All I know is America had half the
wealth of the world 20 years ago and
five percent of the world population.
We've lost half that wealth and it's
that as we get more powerful,
they get more powerful and the elite had
been trying to domesticate America.
Not that we're perfect,
but we've got ideas of industry and
ideas and doing things that change
everything.
And so The really this planet want to
kill competition.
They want to consolidate control.
They want to end the internet of
governments.
That's America.
They were about,
if hillary would have won,
they would have censored the.
Oh yeah.
How are they going to look it up?
Look it up.
I'm actually surprised how fast that's
all.
Putting the pieces together.
There were about to do it.
Okay.
Tell them the headline is obama
establishes ministry of truth three
weeks before trump takes office one week
after a trump's elected.
So ministry of truth being something
that stops fake news,
the news the government doesn't agree
with,
right?
So The problem becomes,
how do we decide what's fake science?
Go back,
please go back please.
Obama quietly signs the countering
disinformation and propaganda act into
law.
Wow.
late on friday with the us population
embracing the upcoming holidays and
oblivious of most news emerging from the
administration,
obama quietly signed into law the 2017
national defense authorization act,
which authorizes $611,000,000,000
for the military in 2017.
In His statement,
obama said blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
Whereas it say,
he says lots of over the governor's
board of governors,
the fcc federalize the media,
meaning federalized television shows and
radio transmissions,
your website,
old galaxy.
She your website,
my website.
Everybody's website.
What do you guys.
What are you doing?
She says obama last minute bills like
all that shit.
He signed shit.
Read down a little lower.
It says in the bill,
we're going to federalize committee.
Put it back.
Was going to find a.
We're going to federalize communications
and put the cia over the board of
governors of the federal communications.
That sounds so crazy.
Did you would have been subject to that
shit.
Could easily.
You can't talk about that.
No more.
Of course hillary would have won.
That would've happened.
Dude.
See,
I wonder if people would have ever went
for that.
That seems.
Let me show at trump does.
He is like up till two in the morning.
Everybody knows tweeting twitter video
clips.
He gets on the internet now.
He'S a conspIracy theorist,
which means any questions about trump?
He's got.
I'm not saying trump's perfect.
I'm going to keep trump honest.
Anything.
I'm going to come out against him.
The point is is that he's a different
kind of thing and you can keep a rogue
element.
Nine slash 11.
Is he
going to do anything about that?
Already exposed the fact that elements
of the government work with Saudi Arabia
to launch the September 11th attacks 16
years ago,
going to reopen that shit.
He said he will.
You think that.
Imagine that.
Imagine the re.
Imagine alien bases on the moon.
Please tell them to release that
information,
but the alien bases on the next
question.
What does he know about geoengineering?
What does he know about aliens?
Not.
Not about aliens.
Fuck,
no,
no.
I want to know about chem trails.
You don't say fuck aliens.
Okay.
Alright,
let's do it.
I'm back on back on Donald Trump call
lately.
I'm holding on aliens and alien bigfoot
10 years ago.
Go ahead,
ring,
ring.
Here we go.
Hi alex.
Oh mr.
president,
what's going on?
Well,
whatever the agenda forward to cut
taxes.
Do you think?
Well,
I should know about those secret space
patients.
Wow.
Alex,
you've got to come to trump tower for
those meetings.
I'll come to trump tower.
I to know about aliens.
Hey asked trump if he wants to learn
some jujitsu.
Half a fly to New York to be with.
You want to Be drunk?
I want to see the bodies.
Alien bodies will go to a trump on the
show.
Alex,
he mentioned trump on the show.
That would be huge for him.
Probably not a good idea for anybody.
No.
I don't know if he wanted joe.
I don't care if you're too cool for
this.
Well,
I.
we have to get the fuck out of here for
sure.
Let's talk about whether or not we're
going to eat or anything else,
but uh,
it's already 5:00,
so we're at a three and a half hours in.
Is there anything more that you have to
say before we get out of here?
Let me get another question.
Is it?
No,
no.
Eddie,
I want to ask alex.
No,
I mean literally I really shake the
truth,
tell the truth and force.com
has all our articles,
our research,
our videos,
our podcasts,
what we do and I'm not left or right.
I'm not liberal or conservative.
I'm really trying to find out what's
going on in the world.
And so after all these years,
joe has been a.
I love really good questions.
You kind of knew all of this.
I was going to bring up.
You just keep you just get crazy and you
want to keep going and keep going and
keep going to keep going.
But I think sometimes you got to go,
okay,
hold that thought.
Expand and explain because a lot of
times things that.
But hold on a second eddie.
Things that are in your head,
self explanatory.
You already know about it if there's a
giant percentage of the people that are
listening to this have no idea what
you're talking about.
I get it.
I want to say this for the joe rogan
listeners,
have an open mind.
You heard him for three and a half
hours.
Download that app.
That info wars app started listening to
him.
Eddie,
why don't you do your show and info
wars.
That's the move to eddie Bravo radio
comes back on info wars.
I would do that rogan's champlain,
but listen,
but listen.
Okay,
but.
Oh,
but listen,
I'm focusing on effect.
All
I want people,
I give him a chance.
He doesn't know shit about space,
but when it comes to politics to.
Yeah.
When it comes to politics,
he's.
He's a fucking master.
He's.
He's like,
he's like helio gracie and that's a
compliment space.
He's.
Joe wrote about jamie pulled something
out was he signed this countering
foreign propaganda and disinformation
act of 2016 to build.
Expresses the sense of this bill
expresses the sense of congress that
what a weird expression.
Okay,
what are we looking at?
This is that bill,
that anti propaganda bill,
foreign governments,
including the government of the russian
federation in China,
used Him for this information,
other propaganda tools to undermine the
national security objectives of the
United States and key allies and
partners.
The us government should develop a
comprehensive strategy to counter
foreign disinformation and propaganda
and assert leadership and developing a
fact base strategic narrative,
and an important element of this
strategy should be to help promote an
independent press and countries that are
vulnerable to foreign disinformation.
Translate that msm is on the ropes,
are panicking.
They'll want to shut down their
competition.
What american watching this or listening
doesn't think they should decide what
they should listen to it not.
Do you think that would be ever
accepted?
That they would allow people,
someone that works in the government to
censor websites and podcasts.
Vamos signed already happened.
Yeah,
but this one,
China,
they signed a bill to dry it.
Whoa.
Crazy.
Notice how I tell you damn bill,
one of the things about podcasts is that
they're basically just a pure
conversation.
It's just peopLe sitting down and
talking and if you.
If you stop pure conversations,
I mean that is like one of the most
heinous formed.
Essentially.
It's too late.
You can't say you can't make a try.
You can try,
but if they really did get into office
and dave really did try to implement
some sort of a transition process,
I almost wish hillary would have won
because that could have been outside the
power.
I keep trump on the list,
not attacked.
Trump does something wrong.
It's hard to find,
but he makes some mistakes like torture,
iphone codes or whatever,
but so torture you think is just.
It doesn't work.
It's not just at work.
It makes us look terrible.
It's a foreign country lowers us to
their level.
Yeah,
exactly.
But trump came out and tortured two days
ago and said,
okay,
so he changed his mind.
He's good on stuff like that.
That's very unusual.
Waking up and when you wake up,
you change your mind.
I was also independently wealthy.
That's one of the things that's probably
a huge factor in this scabbing.
He's not part of the obama.
Hillary.
That's what I'm saying is that there's
no calculation.
I just treat you like I want to be
treated.
Big stuff is happening.
It's a very exciting time to ask you
this.
Before we.
Before we wrap this up,
you know,
if trump is this new stage of politics
or new type of politician,
what kind of person do you think would
be like literally the perfect person to
run this country and would the perfect
person
do ron paul?
Ron paul is great,
but I think as somebody who's worked
hard in private business who really has
a sense of success,
who loves America,
who has been through the gauntlet of
demonization attacks and dealt with it,
I think it's Donald Trump.
I mean,
you look at what he'S been through,
man,
who's been through this,
been a winner over and I'm not in some
cults,
Donald Trump.
I think I want to hate him.
I want to not believe he's so good,
but man,
when he calls up and can like read your
mind and knows what you were just
thinking about,
you're like,
man,
this guy is like god or the devil.
This tax thing is very fascinating.
It's very interesting people.
It seemed to me the main street of
billionaires are gonna pay it to me.
Every time I turn on my iphone.
You know what I didn't ask for fucking
fox news bulletin.
They force feed me every morning.
Sienna.
So one of the joe rogan experience for
info wars.
That's why you gotta say chanel,
because joe's real.
I'm real.
You're real.
Whether we're perfectly,
no matter.
We want to be real.
Everyone should humint human
intelligence support this podcast and
info wars and the joe rogan experience
and make this dominant,
which it already is.
just to say,
listen,
bitches,
you may force feed eddie bravo,
a bunch of cnn,
fox news shit every morning,
but you're fucking getting the joe rogan
experience up your fucking ass.
Holy christ.
Every time I turn on my phone and look
at what a cnn trying to fucking force
feed.
Yeah.
Since when does the iphone force feed
you?
The possessed demonic entity type?
Just a second.
Cooper.
I trump disease.
I'm on the anti trump,
but disadvantaged super nice guy.
He seems like a nice guy.
Cia.
He worked there like in college right
now.
Beyond tHat,
beyond that,
he admitted it.
He's part of the light whip.
Cia.
Real.
Wait a minute.
see I as a whip division if you're the
aster family.
lucky is or the vanderbilt,
vanderbilt,
john j.mr.
Myrick smith.
His name was my name too,
if you.
All right folks,
that's a wrap.
Now it's not.
Know.
Make fun of me at the very end.
We're talking about dental transcending
information here.
Job.
I think sometimes we're talking about
info wars.com
and joe rogan experience and andy bravo.
No problem.
Hey,
Soon to return to do a rock and roll
conspiracy theory.
Oh,
it's your network.
If not,
he believes the cia.
Curious,
how does this go as well as you thought
beyond that or better?
This was fun,
which is awesome.
I enjoyed it.
I you think of it?
What?
What did you think?
Your nine slash 11.
I thought it'd be exactly like this is
as good as I could have hoped.
We had good time.
We had a lot of laughs.
We talked about some real shit.
We brought up some news articles that
confirm a lot of crazy things that
you're saying that makes me like all
those new arrests there,
new arrest about pedophiles and sex
slaves.
Like holy shit,
if that's real.
What story was,
what news source was?
That story was right and how many
different is it like all over the place
in India and a bunch of different news
sources that one about the sex slaves
and being released.
It's associated children,
so it's a mainstream story.
I'm sitting here thinking trump is a
major force global force right now.
Trump and he talks to Alex Jones,
Alex Jones,
toxic joe rogan,
and I'm here because of joe rogan.
I'm like,
holy goddamn shit.
We got some kind of lightening bolt
going through the world right now,
but it's not like joe's like.
It's like all of us together.
We're all there.
It had to be like this for it to be like
this every,
every day before today,
however it went down.
How to be like this for us,
for this to happen.
Are you wanting to be better than eight
years before I come back and joe,
next time you're so you got to come and
studio.
We have to do an interview.
ThAt store that foreign and 74 stories
arrested was laying many,
many,
many major news sites.
It's crazy how it's real.
This isn't galactic thing going down
right now,
man.
There's some interesting things are
happening to people and it's happening
at an accelerated rate and we're all
part of it.
Everybody listening to this,
everybody talking to their friends and
everybody rewind,
awaken everybody,
reading the internet.
Everybody watching documentaries and
reading books.
Everybody understanding that we know
more about how things work today than we
ever have before and it's weirder than
we ever thought.
Isn't this discovering incredible.
The crazy thing is is when people aren't
you,
you're just not asleep and awake.
You're asleep and then you're partially
awake.
You know about,
oh,
you discover,
you saw zike guys for the first time.
Oh,
you're partially awake.
You don't know about all this other
stuff.
So when you hear about all the other
stuff,
you still got that mentality where like,
that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
People are partially awake.
Not,
not everybody's bullshit though.
That's the problem.
There's a lot of wacky conspiracies out
there.
Monster dinosaurs aren't real shark.
They believe it's a a greenland shark.
Sharks or they think it's a shark that's
like a millions,
millions of years old and got into that
water back when it was connected to the
ocean because it's an ancient creature
and they used to think they were
extinct,
but now they don't anymore.
They found some.
So they,
they,
they think the loch ness monster.
That makes sense.
Or like a tWenty five foot right about
what you get your information from.
Scientists from guys can't talk over
each other,
but that's what it comes down to.
Hardly talking.
I know,
but he's talking about talk when you're
talking about a greenland shark arm.
No.
We end the show.
Yes.
Eddie bravo back.
No,
no,
no.
I'm gonna.
fuck you up.
And my left hand is my strongest because
I'm south.
Everybody have beautiful.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for tuning in to episode nine
slash one bravo,
Alex Jones and joe rogan signing off.
Alright joe.
we got to do it again soon.